ok bonjour à tous bonjour
collègues que vous connaissez Partenaires visiteurs euh
participants pour la première fois, euh, c'est mon super
plaisir de vous accueillir ici aujourd'hui pour euh
ce que nous croyons, je dis que nous croyons
parce que personne n'a réussi à trouver le euh
la date du Club des opérateurs d'origine
à ce que nous croyons être le
20e euh Operators Club donc si quelqu'un est
j'ai un meilleur rendez-vous, j'en suis heureux
discuter d'une guerre particulière, bienvenue dans un
première fois
participants euh à un collègue venant de
euh de notre opération de la tête
bureau euh collègues et partenaires comme
eh bien, euh, les gens qui vont être euh
parler et participer à ça euh
matin, l'événement de ce matin sera
être également diffusé via YouTube
tu as quelques euh caméra dans le
revenir euh pour permettre à nos collègues euh
assister à distance euh pour participer à
je sais ce qui se passe euh je le suis
je pense en particulier aux gens de
L'Australie en Inde dans le
Les Philippines au Cameroun, euh au milieu
L'Est de l'Afrique du Sud qui n'a pas pu venir
aujourd'hui pour ceux d'entre vous qui ne le savent pas
moi, je m'appelle AER, je suis à la tête du
ligne de service de maintenance opérationnelle et
avec euh Richard, je serai ton
hôte
aujourd'hui avant de plonger dans le
agenda particulièrement chargé euh quelques sécurités
euh instruction, on me dit qu'il n'y a pas euh
exercice de sécurité aujourd'hui, donc si vous entendez un
alarme de sécurité, c'est probablement la vraie
chose et on nous demande de nous enfuir
par les sorties que vous pouvez voir
marqué des deux côtés ici euh à travers le
les portes, euh, en bas des escaliers maintenant
retour à
entreprise disant que les 12 derniers mois
j'ai été très occupé depuis le dernier
Le Club des opérateurs sera probablement un
euh, c'est un euphémisme dans le contexte mondial
d'un climat d'instabilité géopolitique
changer la flambée de l’inflation ou le réseau routier
a continué de croître au cours des deux dernières années
du mois, il y a eu quelques
ajout ou nouvelles sections ajoutées à notre
réseaux existants en Irlande en
particulier euh et aussi en Australie avec
les euh euh nouvelles sections de tunnels
être ajouté à l'Ouest connecte et
couples quelques nouvelles sections à venir
ajouté dans les prochains mois euh le
West Connect est euh, c'est le plus grand
infrastructure infrastructure routière
projet en Australie et le deuxième
le plus long tunnel du monde donc
définitivement un produit phare pour nous un
il y a quelques mois, en juin, nous aussi
j'ai signé le contrat pour euh le
de retour au projet le Ring de 66 kilomètres
Route autour d'Almati au Kazakhstan euh et
quelques semaines plus tard, euh, nous avons commencé
l'opération et euh l'opération
du projet de recharge à flux libre
le résultat de tout cela est maintenant
nous gérons un réseau de 4 200 kilomètres
d'autoroutes dont 98 kilomètres
tunnels qui confirme notre position de
opérateur onm leader mondial, eh bien
en avance sur nos principaux concurrents si tous
de notre réseau était dans un pays, disons
La France par exemple réalisera 46%
de la Route Nationale euh ou de l'Autoroute
réseau si c'était au Royaume-Uni, ce serait
58% donc c'est juste pour te donner une idée
il est toujours facile de se rappeler que nous sommes
un opérateur et que nous sommes présents en 21
pays mais ce n'est pas nécessairement le cas
ça veut rien dire quand tu ne mets pas tout
ces
ensemble, euh, pendant cette année-là, nous avons été
euh, je gère 3 millions de véhicules par jour
sur ce réseau, ce qui représente une augmentation de 25%
depuis
2021 euh pendant cette même période on a vu
le nombre d'accidents auxquels nous avons assisté
46 000 euh d'incident réduit d'un facteur
de 16%, ce qui est également un excellent
réalisation nous gérons six millions
transaction par an dont 56% sont
les transactions de télépéage qui
confirme les tendances mondiales vers
Le recouvrement des péages électroniques et le
il est important d'investir beaucoup de temps
dans la conquête énergétique et la sécurisation de nouvelles
part de marché dans ce domaine
segment sur le front de la gestion d'actifs euh
nous gérons au nom de nos clients euh a
un pipeline de projets de 15 milliards
euros euh nous vous aidons
les gars ou les opérations mais aussi externes euh
clients, euh, nous leur fournissons une assistance
poursuivre leur parcours vers la norme ISO 501
certification et nous gérons à tout moment
dans le temps, environ 10 actifs numériques
Projets de gestion soit pour nous-mêmes
opérations ou externes
clients, nous avons maintenant établi notre
toute première empreinte carbone
sur l'ensemble du portefeuille onm, pas seulement
Route, euh, sans surprise, la route est là
l'empreinte carbone est assez importante
euh et une part importante du groupe
euh, empreinte carbone, nous avions des émissions
2022 de 40 000 um tonnes de
CO2 euh qui représente environ 35% du groupe
empreinte qui n'est pas surprenante et
nous nous fixons un objectif difficile de
Une réduction de 5 % sur un an en ligne avec
le euh sbti la cible basée sur la science
initiative euh, c'est exactement ce que le
le groupe s'en sort aussi bien euh sur ce front
nous avons commencé à travailler sur notre
plan de réduction pour les étapes un et deux euh
émissions en fait, nous avons commencé bien avant
ce genre de U de principe où même
établi travaillant sur la réduction de l'énergie
L'éclairage LED projette la production d'énergie solaire
des projets comme celui-ci nous nous nous nous
mis en œuvre il y a quelques mois dans
Allemagne et avant cela devant et dans
en Australie, c'est intéressant aussi, nous
nous, euh, nous commençons à avoir l'air très
activement auprès de nos flottes de véhicules avec un
accompagnement de l'équipe achats groupe
qui est une source importante de
émission de carbone comme vous l'imaginez euh
et nous examinons systématiquement les
L’intérêt des achats environnementaux
véhicule convivial chaque fois que nous le pouvons dans n'importe quel
cas sur chaque nouvel appel d'offres que nous faisons
cet exercice quand il n'est pas possible de
acheter ce genre de véhicule ou se mobiliser
ce genre de véhicule nous recherchons également
dans des carburants efficaces en carbone, tels que
comme le hvo 100 qui est actuellement
actuellement testé en Irlande et sera
testé bientôt dans d'autres euh zones géographiques euh
nous opérons dans euh 86% de notre
opération, euh, nous atteignons également zéro
agrochimique euh, ce qui est génial
réalisation il reste un peu à faire pour
atteindre 100% mais nous y sommes définitivement
suivre celui-là en août 2023, nous
avons démarré notre cockpit de données, nous avons lancé notre
cockpit de données, je suis presque sûr que cela joue un rôle important
d'entre vous sauraient ce que le cockpit de données
ce qui devrait probablement être une marque, euh
ceci Cet acronyme euh c'est un
initiative lancée au printemps
sous la direction de Richard et
ce qui nous donne pour la première fois un
image globale des opérations clés
indicateurs à travers le opérationnel euh
Réseau qui nous permet de collecter
informations précieuses sur sur sur netor
mieux identifier et traiter les effets indésirables
les trains quand ils surviennent, je les fournis aussi
informations utiles pour démontrer la
où sommes-nous ce que nous faisons comment nous
fonctionner et la valeur que nous pouvons générer
pour tous les clients, c'est aussi un outil très utile
et Benchmark très puissant pour nous permettre
pour construire une proposition très compétitive
en avant, euh, tout cela s'est passé dans le
contexte de transformation du Groupe Global
le programme a un impact sur l'avenir qui, comme vous
savoir a continué sinon accéléré
au cours des deux derniers mois avec un
une nouvelle organisation est en cours de mise en place
dans le but de positionner le groupe
en tant que leader mondial du conseil en um
ingénierie et exploitation de la construction
et
maintenance, cela a conduit à d'importantes
des changements dans notre façon de faire les choses
nous avons trois euh lignes de service, euh
que le euh euh Conseil et exploitation
est celui dont nous faisons partie euh
intervenant ou opérant dans quatre régions
France Moyen-Orient et Asie du Sud
Pacifique et, euh, Asie de l'Est, Europe et
L'Afrique euh et ces changements sont de
cours venant avec des changements dans la façon dont nous
nous faisons les choses avec lesquelles nous opérons livrer
projet euh avec l'objectif de faire
tirer le meilleur parti de notre proximité avec
client et partenaires de la région mais
également les experts mondiaux ou l'expertise de
notre réseau de
opération, nous sommes désormais pleinement organisés
équipé euh pour soutenir avec le support
fonction dont nous avons besoin pour la suite
développement de notre activité et et et
le programme de transformation nous nous avons
euh, nous avons développé, nous avons de nouveaux outils
à notre disposition comme le data cockpit
nous avons le jeu euh avec notre
empreinte existante et nouveau projet
En arrivant, nous avons les gens bien sûr
nous-mêmes ou nos experts du secteur
l'expertise du groupe également
nous avons même les Playmates parce que
en plus de Road onm the O onm
la ligne de service inclut désormais euh l'aéroport
mobilité et services urbains et bientôt
Rail Onm en tant que nous sommes sur le point de signer notre
tout premier rail lors d'un projet dans le prochain
quelques semaines, donc nous sommes prêts pour
ce qui vient ensuite et ce qui vient ensuite est
euh, l'excellence opérationnelle, c'est drôle
c'est assez le thème du jour d'aujourd'hui
opérateurs Club um et bio heureux
la coïncidence était aussi le thème du
assemblée générale une réunion des managers nous
j'ai eu hier avec un certain nombre d'entre vous, euh
avant de te remettre le euh le euh le
parole à Richard pour qu'il présente
l'agenda chargé, nous avons ça
matin peut-être deux questions, qu'est-ce que c'est
l'excellence opérationnelle dans le cadre de
l'exploitation et l'entretien et pourquoi
ce serait bien de viser euh sur quoi
question il y a beaucoup de potentiel
réponses, vous pouvez même demander au chat GPT qui
c'est exactement ce que Richard a fait il y a quelques
il y a des mois, quand nous avons commencé à parler
l'excellence opérationnelle, vous obtiendrez un
réponse intéressante qui mentionnera
concept de conformité continue
Amélioration des performances même au-delà
performance, euh, nous en avons débattu hier
avec les managers de General M, je veux dire certains de
Vue et une définition issue de
c'est ce que je pensais être très très toi
Je connais Spaton, il est dit d'être celui que le
autres
suivez, j'aime cette définition, c'est
assez simple tu sais et tu veux
donner l'exemple, pour autant que je sois
l'excellence opérationnelle concernée est que
euh maintenant, pourquoi pourquoi voudrions-nous
être celui que les autres suivent et
Je vois quatre raisons à cela : la première
un, je pense que c'est dans O ADN au cœur d'un
est un est un est un
est une organisation qui résout les problèmes
je sais que c'est ce que nous faisons même sur notre
opération donc je pense que tu sais
l'excellence opérationnelle dans ce contexte
c'est tout à fait logique la deuxième raison
c'est parce que je pense que c'est exactement ce que
nos clients et partenaires attendent
nous, c'est ce qu'ils sont votre client et
les partenaires attendent de vous euh comme le
l'expert de notre domaine le troisième est
parce que nos équipes nos collaborateurs les
les personnes travaillant sur notre projet sont également
je m'attends à ce que les autres, euh, entre
la conformité qui n'est que la
le respect quotidien des
contrat et obtenir ou aller au-dessus et
au-delà de cela, la plupart d'entre eux, en particulier
chez le jeune on veut aller au-delà de lui
nous voulons changer le monde et je pense que nous
il faut leur donner une chance de le faire
final mais pas des moindres parce que tu es dans un monde
ça change à un rythme très rapide euh
Je pense que nous devrions toujours viser à faire
mieux vaut être plus sûr, plus vert euh et utiliser le
Les technologies les processus les gens
je vais devoir le faire donc ce sont pour moi
les quatre raisons pour lesquelles devrions-nous viser
pour l'excellence opérationnelle
euh et j'ai dit la définition que je
je pense que c'est celui que nous devrions être, nous devrions
je viserai maintenant, je reviens à toi
Richard présentera l'ordre du jour de
aujourd'hui merci oui merci
j'ai couru donc c'est un très grand plaisir
pour être ici aujourd'hui, nous sommes environ 120
des gens ici, nous avons des gens dans le
Philippines personnes au Mexique personnes au
Inde et autres pays d'Europe
nous regarde aussi donc c'est vraiment génial
donc comme tout le monde l'a dit, nous avons décidé de le faire
parler d'excellence opérationnelle, c'est un
contester ce que fait l'opérationnel
l'excellence signifie que tout le monde est différent
définition qu'est-ce que cela signifie pour votre
entreprise, qu'est-ce que cela signifie pour votre équipe
qu'est-ce que cela signifie pour vous au quotidien
en plus une signature c'est fort
nous savons que nous respectons le contrat
tous les clients nous disent qu'EDG devrait livrer
mais est-ce suffisant, pouvons-nous ajouter plus de valeur
à nos clients pouvons-nous fournir mieux
les déplacements chez nos clients sur autoroute peuvent
nous apportons des conditions de travail plus sûres à nos
le personnel pouvons-nous lutter contre le changement climatique pouvons-nous
préparez-vous à la prochaine crise parce que
n'oublions pas qu'au cours de la dernière
trois ans, nous avons eu deux crises majeures
19 euh guerre en Ukraine et nous devions être
extrêmement agile et ce n'est pas avec
conforme au qpi avec lequel votre agile est
l'excellence opérationnelle afin de
faites la lumière aujourd'hui sur les opérations
l'excellence nous avons été nous sommes très
Heureusement, nous avons un grand panel de
différentes personnes dont nous avons un expert
En Australie, nous avons des opérateurs de euh
Australie et Royaume-Uni et enfin nous avons
un grand client très avancé sur l'ESG de
La France et le Canada qui présenteront le
approche alors j'appelle Ginette Aiden Shen
Andy et Ellen viennent ici
s'il te plaît, alors Sean, c'est toi le
d'abord
ouais, salut, bonjour, je m'appelle Shan McGuire.
on m'a dit que j'avais 15 minutes alors je vais
passer immédiatement à la diapositive suivante sur laquelle je travaille
pour Microsoft et je veux parler de
pourquoi l'excellence opérationnelle ou qu'est-ce que
en fait
méchant et pourquoi c'est intéressant pour
groupe et comment il est lié au design
c'est ce que je pensais il y a quelques mois, j'ai assisté à
conférence sur l'excellence opérationnelle à
Amsterdam et l'une des choses qui
Ce qui me reste à l'esprit, c'est que tu ne peux pas changer un
organisation, vous ne pouvez changer que CH
individus dans l'organisation et il
vraiment fait clic pour moi car dans le
final design thinking opérationnel
l'excellence en essayant d'atteindre la même chose
il s'agit de changer les gens, alors qu'est-ce que c'est
le design thinking et j'ai réalisé
400 ateliers de design thinking dans ma vie
J'arrive à la conclusion qu'il s'agit vraiment de
donner aux gens une voix pour parler et vous
se concentrer et écouter ce qu'ils ont à dire
disons que nous avons beaucoup de gens brillants
les organisations et la première inclination
c'est que je vais essayer de résoudre mon problème dans plusieurs
Dans certains cas, ils ne peuvent pas dormir même lorsqu'ils sont
en vacances, conseil en arrière-plan
leur cerveau les bouge, comment peut-il
ils résolvent leur problème et une réponse
peut-être que tu invites simplement des gens
dans un atelier et vous
écoute et c'est beaucoup plus difficile à faire, euh
pour beaucoup de gens parce qu'ils étaient
aux commandes, les managers
prendre la décision, c'est très difficile pour
à eux de le remettre à l'équipe et
il suffit de prendre du recul et d'écouter, mais le
l'avantage que vous obtiendrez, c'est que vous l'obtiendrez
obtenez une contribution considérable et vous serez
capable de prendre de nouvelles et meilleures décisions
avec cette entrée externe, alors comment pouvez-vous
utiliser le design thinking dans de nombreux cas
je pense que tu peux l'utiliser pour concevoir cool
des applications ou des biens de consommation mais vous
je peux vraiment l'utiliser pour des problèmes commerciaux
ainsi que de petits groupes de discussion en un et un
une demi-heure ou deux heures ou une grande
projet de transformation plusieurs millions
projet en dollars qui cherche vraiment à
vision mais aussi pour des ateliers stratégiques
pour que vos managers réfléchissent vraiment
les marchés et ce que sont vos clients
ce que font vos concurrents
décider dans quelle direction vous voulez
apportez votre organisation et n'oubliez pas
à propos des partenaires gouvernementaux et fournisseurs
donc à chaque fois tu as
Les communications et c'est ce que vous êtes
va dépenser une grande partie de votre
il est temps de réfléchir à un design
atelier de réflexion pour obtenir des compléments
saisissez la chose vraiment importante à
comprendre, c'est que chaque participant à votre
L'atelier s'accompagne d'un énorme
connaissances, idées et vie
expérience et tu es vraiment bon et
c'est une sorte de mantra, plus tu es
écoute, mieux tu vas, alors pour moi
disons qu'une métrique pour un atelier est
si j'ai un atelier avec un partenaire ou un
client plus le client est le partenaire
parle mieux pour moi parce que le
plus de nouvelles informations, je le ferai
la deuxième chose est ce qui est opérationnel
excellence, il existe de nombreuses définitions
mais je pense que ce projet résume réellement
cela réduit le temps de trajet global
d'environ 170 000 personnes chaque jour
6 6 heures à 3 heures c'est opérationnel
l'excellence et la définition est
l'excellence opérationnelle, c'est
optimiser les coûts et les efforts en ressources
et diriger une entreprise prospère au
en même temps et je sais une chose que je veux
mettre l'accent sur la réflexion sur la conception et
l'excellence opérationnelle c'est une affaire
outil et si cela ne vous aide pas
les affaires ne font pas
mais le dénomination commune là ou celui
chose qui est vraiment difficile, la seule chose
c'est à dire l'excellence opérationnelle
fais-le, c'est comment peux-tu trouver le bon
équilibre entre les processus humains et
technologie et aidez vos employés à
avoir une vie heureuse parce qu'à la fin tu
vous ne pouvez pas diriger une organisation si votre
les employés ne sont pas contents ou du moins vous
n'obtiendra pas l'optimum de
donc, euh, c'est l'une des chutes du gouffre
J'ai vu de nombreuses organisations, euh, managers
viens et dis soyons opérationnels
Excellence, soyons meilleurs mais tu as besoin
pour leur fournir également le bon euh
outils dont ils disposent, gestionnaires de trafic, euh
employés d'entretien des opérateurs de trafic
inspecteur CT gestionnaires d'exploitants routiers
tout le monde a besoin des bons outils alors réfléchissez
sur les outils dont vous avez besoin pour
pour permettre à vos employés et vous devez
trouver le bon euh disons le bon endroit
entre la technologie, la motivation humaine et
des récompenses pour faire profiter vos employés
le
travail maintenant, la chose vraiment intéressante c'est
si tu mets ces deux choses ensemble
d'un côté tu as vraiment euh
l'excellence opérationnelle fonctionne et c'est
sur les managers qui réfléchissent à la manière dont ils peuvent
optimiser ou améliorer l'organisation et
c'est vraiment une question de gestion
outil pour réussir afin que les managers
ils ont une excellence opérationnelle ils
réfléchissez vraiment à la façon dont je peux le connecter
avec mes objectifs commerciaux et un
au niveau organisationnel, cela signifie quelque chose
complètement autrement, cela signifie essentiellement le
l'organisation doit bien comprendre
c'est ce que la direction veut faire, comment
allons-nous mettre en œuvre cela dans notre
organisation, mais comme nous le savons tous,
vraiment, la chose la plus difficile à résoudre est le
l'employé l'est et les employés ne le feront tout simplement pas
suivez s'ils ne comprennent pas pourquoi
tu le fais et eux non
comprendre comment cela va les aider
et tout est question de motivation et d'avoir
ces employés se sentent respectés et
apprécié maintenant, ce qui est bien, c'est le design
la réflexion peut vous aider dans tout cela
trois étapes, la première est sur le
au niveau des employés, faites participer vos employés
ces ateliers les engagent, écoutez
comprendre leurs peurs et leurs
aspirations au niveau organisationnel
le design thinking peut vous aider à créer
modèle opérationnel centré sur l'humain
je vais vous aider et sur la gestion
niveau, c'est vraiment une question de réduction des risques
parce que vous voulez vous assurer que votre
Le programme de proog d'excellence opérationnelle est
cela ne créera pas plus de perturbations
que les avantages dans l'organisation donc
réfléchissez à la façon dont ces deux-là peuvent fonctionner
ensemble, il s'agit de construire le
organisation, l'autre est vraiment
sur l'écoute profonde des gens
excellence opérationnelle en conception
penser, c'est à la fois comprendre
guider et gérer le comportement humain et
diriger une entreprise prospère et c'est
le lien convaincant pourquoi ces deux-là vont bien
ensemble, c'est un exemple de notre
ateliers que nous avons fait hier, nous avons passé
10 heures, euh, à écouter les gens et eux
travailler sur les problèmes que vous pouvez avoir
conversations pendant le déjeuner et en quelque sorte
regarde le
résultats, ceci a été dit la dernière chose, euh,
de nombreuses organisations que vous voyez aussi, nous avons essayé
tout six stigmates nettoyer peu importe
ça ne marche pas, volons-en quelques-uns
consultants et ils vont résoudre un
problème c'est comme si l'avion venait d'arriver
et ils disent que alors tout va bien
va s'en aller n'arrivera pas parce que
l'excellence opérationnelle est vraiment
stratégie à long terme pour le changement culturel
et rappelez-vous que vous ne pouvez pas changer un
organisation que vous pouvez seulement changer
individus donc la deuxième chose que je veux
parler, c'est euh de The Habit Loop
parce que je pense que l'excellence opérationnelle est
profondément lié aux habitudes et je vais
te montrer ce que tu peux réellement apprendre
d'une souris qui court dans un labyrinthe et
trouver un chocolat, alors quelles sont les habitudes
l'habitude est un humain entièrement automatisé
activité déclenchée par une file d'attente effectuant
une routine recevant une récompense alors que nous
sais et ceci est un exemple de ce que le
la souris fait quand elle regarde ou
je traverse le laboratoire du labyrinthe
je cherche vraiment les chocolats
ça va leur prendre du temps mais
après la cinquième sixième itération, vous êtes
je vais juste tu vas ouvrir le
porte, ils vont courir et prendre le
le chocolat, maintenant la même chose se produit pour
les humains parce que c'est généralement euh le
comment les médias sociaux explorent nos habitudes de travail
tu as un téléphone portable, il te sonne
J'entends une file d'attente, c'est immédiatement oh je veux
pour savoir ce qui se passe et ensuite toi
obtenez la récompense lorsque vous ouvrez réellement
votre compte de réseau social, vous voyez votre
j'aime ou vos commentaires le fait est
tout entre la file d'attente et le
la récompense est entièrement automatisée et c'est un
chose vraiment cool parce que 40% de votre
travail quotidien et c'est vrai à chaque fois
vous vous réveillez est entièrement automatisé et ceux
activités donc si vous les comptez ensemble
environ 3 heures de ta journée de travail, tu es
faire, disons, presque inconsciemment et
le fait est que cela soulage le cerveau
en fait, je les fais vraiment
des tâches complexes en les automatisant entièrement
et ça te rend bien plus
efficace, donc la bonne nouvelle est que vous pouvez changer
euh les habitudes existantes que tu peux reprogrammer
eux mais tu dois t'assurer que tu euh
vraiment comprendre comment
travailler donc je vais vous donner un exemple que nous avons
ici Joe ouais, il étudie pour un examen
l'après-midi, il est fatigué, il est fatigué
il va au
cafétéria et euh, il s'achète un
biscuit CH au chocolat et sa récompense est
je vais avoir des conversations et j'apprécie
c'est quoi le problème pourquoi est-ce mauvais
habitude, il prend deux kilos tous les
semaine donc c'est vraiment dur pour lui alors comment
pouvez-vous réellement le changer et l'un des
les stratégies c'est euh que tu quittes le
faire la queue
pareil et tu penses à quel est ton
routine, alors comment vas-tu la changer
il comprend en fait ce que c'est
ce qui est vraiment convaincant pour lui, c'est d'avoir le
conversation pour qu'il rencontre des amis, euh
plutôt que d'aller dans la zone des FAC et il
obtient la même ressource euh euh euh récompense et
le problème c'est que tu ne peux pas simplement faire du mal
les habitudes disparaissent, elles sont stockées dans votre
cerveau, tu ne peux pas les arrêter mais toi
vous pouvez les reprogrammer et vous pouvez les réutiliser
d'une meilleure façon, alors voici un
exemple de la pandémie et c'était
vraiment difficile pour tout le monde, surtout pour
les gens en travail à domicile, nous avions une infinité
réunions et ici peut-être le choc
type de résultats et ces résultats sont
de euh juste cette année aux États-Unis 55
millions de réunions chaque semaine 11 millions
par jour 1 milliard par an 71% d'entre eux
les réunions sont considérées comme improductives
euh, le ralentissement économique, disons, 37
Milliards euh perdus et 30 heures 31 heures
par mois en réunions improductives par
mois en moyenne pour chaque employé donc
laisse ce genre de chose c'est quoi ça
signifie réellement pour l'organisation
et si tu pouvais changer de réunion
habitudes pour éradiquer le nombre de
réunions improductives, vous obtiendrez un supplément
31 heures par mois, ce ne serait pas bien
Je veux dire, nous avons tous beaucoup trop de choses à faire
alors peut-être que nous pourrions utiliser ce temps davantage
productif et voici un exemple de la façon dont vous
Je peux reprogrammer cette boucle d'habitude et
voici Joe quelques années plus tard, maintenant c'est un
manager il a une grande équipe il a un
problème, son instinct est oh je suis juste
je vais envoyer une réunion, je veux juste
le problème est de s'en aller et sa récompense est
Je suis super euh énergique, je résous tous les problèmes
problèmes je peux tout déléguer
quel est son véritable désir, en fait
veut plus de temps pour résoudre le sien
problèmes maintenant qu'allons-nous faire comment
allons-nous améliorer cette habitude Loop
eh bien, sa nouvelle file d'attente est toujours la
pareil, il a toujours des problèmes et ils sont
il ne s'en va pas mais il se force
à chaque fois avant d'envoyer une réunion
qu'il va en fait écrire un
ordre du jour, réfléchissez aux avantages
et s'il croit toujours qu'il a besoin d'un
réunion, puis il va l'envoyer
et sinon, il va le supprimer, qu'est-ce que c'est
sa récompense et bien les gens vont dire
eh bien, Joe envoie des réunions qui
il est logique qu'ils soient présents et
il a aussi changé sa récompense dans le
genre moyen, euh, qu'est-ce qui motive le
boucle parce que maintenant quelle est son aspiration
est sa nouvelle envie, je veux assurer mon
l'équipe a plus de temps concentré pour être plus
productif donc c'est une situation gagnant-gagnant
il envoie moins de réunions il passe un
un peu de temps avant de le faire
l'équipe est plus
productive, la bonne nouvelle ici est vraiment
que euh euh tout le monde peut le faire et toi dedans
de nombreux cas ne nécessitent pas d'approbation si souvent
quand tu vas dans une organisation, nous
je veux changer la première chose dont j'ai besoin
nouvel ordinateur, j'ai besoin d'un talkie-walkie, je
besoin de ceci ou de cela mais opérationnel
l'excellence est vraiment une question de progression
des changements que tout le monde peut faire et aussi
pense toujours à comment peux-tu changer
vos habitudes pour avoir plus de succès et
aussi plus heureux et appréciez votre travail
l'équilibre de la vie donc je veux euh avant de le faire
fini, je vous laisse avec une instruction
comment ça va fonctionner et tu as euh
à côté de votre bouteille d'eau pour que l'eau soit
c'est important qu'on sache survivre euh mais aussi
avoir de bonnes habitudes peut aussi être très
important pour vous de survivre dans un
organisation et c'est une simple triche
feuille et l'idée est après le
les présentations sont terminées ouais euh ou
à l'heure du déjeuner ou tu le ramènes à la maison
dans ta poche alors pense au
première chose, qu'est-ce que tu veux réellement
pour changer ouais, écris la routine
vous l'avez et vous souhaitez l'améliorer, vous pouvez
sois n'importe quoi ouais et sois clair sur pourquoi
il faut, euh, l'améliorer, c'est ça
étape numéro un, la deuxième étape est de réfléchir
pourquoi tu fais ça, quelle est la raison
récompense tu es
est-ce que ça te rend fier, n'est-ce pas
te rendre heureux, peux-tu mieux dormir
quelle que soit cette récompense, c'est la troisième chose
c'est vraiment beaucoup plus difficile dans de nombreux cas
c'est quoi la file d'attente c'est quoi le problème
ça te motive parce qu'on a vu le
manager avant que Jo ait un problème, c'est envoyé
la réunion est que c'est vraiment ce qui se passe
en fait, il déclenche son habitude et le
la quatrième chose est de penser à ce que c'est
conduire la boucle et analyser cela pour
découvrez ce qui se passe réellement dans
de retour parce que c'est vraiment ce qui crée
le
répétition ainsi et la dernière la cinquième
l'un est peut-être le plus difficile, créer un
je prévois d'expérimenter et l'idée est euh
ce n'est pas évident comment tu peux le changer
ce qui fonctionne comme nous l'avons vu avant Joe, il
je devais comprendre qu'il ne le ferait pas
achète le euh le cookie qu'il est en fait
j'y vais pour avoir quelques conversations
euh, je pense que c'est une situation gagnant-gagnant pour
tout le monde pour que chaque employé puisse reprogrammer
au moins une mauvaise habitude pour une bonne habitude
nous avons 120 personnes ici dans la salle si
vous pensez à votre organisation complète
c'est vrai pour chaque organisation
ça va être un grand gagnant-gagnant ouais
pour le groupe AIS, c'est une question de dollars
être plus rentable pour les Opex
programme, j'ai dit qu'un programme Opex, c'est
sur le développement de bonnes habitudes pour
l'organisation et bien sûr pour le
employés parce qu'au final c'est vraiment
à propos
les employés, donc c'est à ça que ça ressemble
comme s'il te plaît, ne le fais pas maintenant, je ne veux pas
pour distraire aussi de l'autre euh
présentations, mets-le dans ta poche, euh
ramène-le à la maison, réfléchis-y, duplique-le
distribuez-le à vos équipes mais vraiment
réfléchissez aux habitudes que vous pouvez
développer réellement, c'est l'exemple
de l'atelier que nous avons eu hier
et je vais juste te le rendre
parce que je pense que notre équipe opérationnelle est
assis devant toi et c'est tout
à propos de toi qui change tes habitudes et euh
avoir plus de succès en tant qu'entreprise
ainsi qu'un
individuel et je suis ouvert pour
[Applaudissements]
des questions très impressionnantes Sean donc
exactement 14 minutes et 26 secondes donc
hier, nous avons eu un atelier avec Sean
et explique-nous que nous devons être à l'heure donc
il a des petits Le flets comme ça donc
J'ai imprimé ça hier soir pour faire
bien sûr, nous sommes à l'heure donc c'est terrible
machine donc j'ai eu la chance de le rencontrer
avec Air1 lors d'une conférence mondiale
sur l'excellence opérationnelle, il était donc
je fais un atelier sur quoi Al par jour, euh
design thinking avec 125 personnes au
en même temps assez impressionnant et on finit
avec une histoire vraie et des choses à améliorer donc
merci beaucoup à Shan, y en a-t-il
question que tu aimerais poser
lui peut-être sur le chat ou pour les gens
en direct
super
clair euh donc Sean aussi cet après-midi
organiser un atelier de 45 minutes euh sur
le design thinking donc si tu veux savoir
plus sur le design thinking mais s'il vous plaît
téléchargez l'application engage et
inscrivez-vous car nous avons un
capacité maximale de 25 personnes par personne
Atelier Je veux juste partager une chose
et c'est vraiment important pour moi, euh non
peu importe la quantité de technologie dont nous disposons aujourd'hui
on parle d'Ai et de génératif euh
euh euh Ai et et les chatbots et tout ça
comme ça à la fin c'est une question de
les humains et je pense que le vraiment
chose intéressante à propos du design thinking
ateliers et je fais ça depuis
depuis plus de 10 ans j'écoute vraiment
les gens et tous les projets que j'ai jamais réalisés
rencontré et je viens de l'informatique
industrie je n'ai jamais rencontré de projet
cela a vraiment échoué à cause de problèmes techniques
raisons en fin de compte si un projet
échoue, c'est toujours quelqu'un qui dit oh si
nous l'aurions su dans le
début et dans la plupart des cas c'est vraiment
à propos des humains, alors réfléchis vraiment
design thinking et opérationnel
l'excellence dans l'engagement avec votre
les employés, c'est la vraie chose gagnante
et dans la société d'aujourd'hui, nous ne le faisons vraiment pas
j'ai assez de temps pour les avoir
conversations et ce qui se passe réellement dans
un atelier, c'est donner à votre équipe une expérience complète
journée juste pour avoir ces conversations, pas
perturbé par les emails et autres
appelle encore merci beaucoup
alors maintenant j'aimerais appeler Eden de
De l'Autriche à l'Australie donc très intéressant
parce que je suis ingénieur civil et
la première fois que j'ai entendu parler de Beam pour
exploitation maintenance je n'y croyais pas
dedans, je vois clairement, ouais, c'est chic
ça a l'air bien, c'est cher mais c'est
inutile et continue d'enquêter j'espère
David Simpson n'est pas là, euh et continue
j'y pense et Aiden et son
l'équipe a présenté ce qu'elle fait sur
ce projet est très ambitieux et pour
la première fois que j'ai vraiment pu voir la valeur
et je pouvais voir l'avenir parce que mon
l'opinion est ce qu'aen va présenter
cela va se produire sur tous les projets
parce qu'aujourd'hui
les entrepreneurs font tous du faisceau
présentation et ils sont sur le point de se terminer
au-delà de l'exploitation et de la maintenance
entreprise et nous devrons nous en occuper
soit nous générons de la valeur à travers
le faisceau ou nous allons échouer et et
Eden explore ça et je pense que c'est très
présentation intéressante
remercier
toi, c'est peut-être pour ça qu'on s'entend si bien
fondamentalement, je suis ingénieur civil car
bien jouer principalement dans un
espace mécanique et électrique euh
technologie alors bonjour bonjour et
bonne journée comme on dirait en Australie
maintenant tu sais que je suis l'Australien dans lequel je suis
la chambre va bien alors monte et dis bonjour
jour pour moi tout au long de la journée parce que je suis
bien sûr, cela générera des
des questions donc euh je suis Aiden hu je suis le
directeur général de Fon Hogan donc je suis
je vais prendre un peu de liberté aujourd'hui pour
parler de Fon Hogan, de qui nous sommes et
L'Ouest est également connecté en termes de
schéma parce que le contexte derrière le
schéma à mesure qu'il évoluait, ainsi que le calendrier et
et la technologie qui a évolué depuis
le projet a commencé là où nous en sommes
avec l'application potentielle du Bim dans
le
AIS, je vais vous expliquer un peu à propos de F et Hogan
aussi, donc ma présentation est de savoir comment
egis Leverage La DNC a livré Bim à
mettre en œuvre l’amélioration continue du
phase o et m donc euh parfois on parle
et euh Bim est un langage commun bien B
Bim est l'information du bâtiment
modéliser l'AIS est l'information sur les actifs
système dans notre sens c'est Maximo toi
je pourrais appeler un cmms, c'est différent
acronymes mais pour ma présentation nous allons
faire référence à l'AOS et au DNC a
différentes conférences de dénomination à travers le
globe je comprends euh en Australie nous
appelez ça conception et construction, c'est le
Constructeur et où est le onm mais plus
et plus en jouant dans une gestion d'actifs
espace donc Fon hogis devrais-je te donner un
un peu de contexte quant à qui nous sommes et
comment nous avons évolué, nous sommes en 10 heures
le globe c'est je crois qu'il est 18h. à
Accueil Fon Hogan Eis est un &m euh
à l'origine une société &m notre société
le nom est Fon Hogan Eis onm propriétaire
limite, nous l'avons raccourcie plus récemment
à F et Hogan Eis car le on tend
pour nous empêcher d'être perçus comme un
gestionnaire d'actifs, nous changeons donc
vernaculaire, nous sommes établis là-bas
complètement en 2015 c'est un 5050 entièrement
Incorporé, c'est une société, euh, commune
aventuré entre Fon Hogan Industries
et egis projets Asie Pacifique Je souhaite
parler textuellement d'egis, je présume
tout le monde sait qu'Egis Fon Hogan est un
organisation issue du Nouveau
Zélande et ils jouent principalement dans un
dans un endroit caché, euh mais ils ont un
une technologie plus intelligente qu'ils développent
leurs capacités font un peu de travail dans
rail euh un peu de travail dans l'eau euh et fais
construction de niveau intermédiaire, ils ne le sont pas
jouer avec toutes les grandes entités de
En Australie, ils jouent dans un niveau intermédiaire
ils pourraient faire une route à 50150250 millions de dollars
construction mais ils ne le sont certainement pas
bâtiment
des tunnels donc c'est un match fait au paradis
parce que les capacités de Euh se complètent
pied et Hogan et vice
versa et ce match fait au paradis juste
a récemment eu ses vœux renouvelés comme
bien avec un atelier stratégique
donc c'est un peu important que ça nous donne
autonomie pour chasser plus que seulement l'ouest
se connecte et joue dans l'espace au-delà du simple
onm traditionnel dans
Australie donc Fon Hogan egis était
initialement à Solly pour West connecter le
schéma et je vais vous montrer le schéma dans
termes de l'échelle sur les deux prochaines années
diapositives euh et nous sommes, nous sommes régis par un
convention d'actionnaires selon laquelle l'actionnaire
l'accord était à l'origine entièrement et
uniquement pour l'Occident relie la langue
lequel l'Ouest se connecte et nous étions un
Astuce pour que le poney utilise une phase, nous sommes maintenant euh
nous avons maintenant étendu cet actionnaire
accord pour développer notre profil euh
y compris développer nos systèmes, ce qui est
ce que je vais vous montrer aujourd'hui et notre
portefeuille d'actifs et je parlerai de
un couple qui est euh en ébullition au
moment à partir d'un point d'appel d'offres de
voir donc c'est West Connect pour ceux
que ce n'est pas familier et beaucoup de
les gens sont mais euh, l'Ouest est connecté, euh
Le concept de West Conect est que le
L'aéroport de Sydney sera libéré et
des routes de voyage s'ouvrent vers le nord-ouest
et le sud-ouest de
Sydney, les zones prédominantes que le
la croissance à Sydney est dans le nord-ouest
et au sud-ouest d'un point d'habitation de
vue et l'aéroport est extrêmement
pertinent même s'il y a une seconde
l'aéroport est en construction en ce moment mais
l'aéroport, je sais si je peux faire un a
chose d'écran ici mais vous pouvez voir le
aéroport en bas à droite
coin, je vais juste parler un peu
à travers notre voyage euh parce qu'il a
j'ai eu le contexte avec le modèle Bim et et
ce dont nous avons hérité et nous y allons
pour construire la première étape de West Connect
ouvert en 2017, c'est le coin vert du
tout en haut à gauche, euh, c'était un élargissement
section c'est Brownfield et Greenfield
à prédominance civile et victime Stade B
2019, c'est à ce moment-là que les choses sont vraiment vraiment
a commencé pour nous, c'était le premier des
de nouveaux tunnels seront ouverts
Sydney peu de temps après euh en 2020
le M8 s'est ouvert donc la pièce en pointillé vert
en haut du M4 euh et le bleu en bas du
en bas, c'est le M8 et aussi quoi
ce qui s'est passé, c'est que nous avons hérité en tant que partie
du schéma, le M5 East, c'est un vieux de 23 ans
tunnel maintenant, il avait 20 20 ans quand
nous quand nous avons hérité d'une partie du projet
lorsque le M8 a ouvert le M5 e, il en fait partie
de Westconnect et euh c'était
on m'a dit qu'il y avait un contexte derrière tout ça
la pièce ici est qu'il y en a deux bons
trois ans entre la conception et la construction
ou le développement de la portée, puis le
le bâtiment de l'étape trois, étape 3A, est ouvert
au début de cette année, au début, ça se connecte
et c'est le tunnel sacré, c'est le bleu foncé
section au milieu de cela
présentation et très bientôt cette année
ce sera ou très bientôt c'est imminent
En novembre, il y aura l'ouverture d'un Rosel
dans un
changement je reviendrai sur le timing
parce que c'est important quand je reconnais
le développement du Bim au sens large
contexte, juste quelques choses que nous faisons
euh, nous aimons nous promouvoir, nous avons 33 ans
km d'autoroute et de tunnels et nous sommes 23
km de tunnel droit c'est le deuxième
le plus long du monde lorsque le Rosel
l'échange arrive, il y en a un autre 9
km de Spaghetti Junction sous-gr
avoir le morceau connecté le plus long de
Infrastructures Tunnel routier
infrastructure dans le monde quelque chose
fier
en 2016, c'est comme ça que nous avons grandi, nous avons
mobilisé cinq Actifs en cinq ans en
2016 nous avons créé notre intégré
système de gestion des contrats euh en 2017 il
C'était un début très doux, je pense en arrière
2016, nous étions quatre moi-même et
trois consultants construisant les icms et
et le
AIS en 2017, nous avons amené notre senior
équipe de direction au début où nous
amené une dame qui était une
administrateur devenu compte An
personne qui est devenue notre comptable qui
est devenu notre finance euh finance et
gestionnaire administratif afin que nous soyons devenus le
les actifs ont développé la technologie et euh et
personnes et revenus M4 ouvert en 2019 euh
comme je l'ai dit, le M5 East, le Brownfield
actif qui a été découplé et qui est venu un
quelques mois plus tôt que le M8 le M8
ouvert en 2020 puis le lien plus tôt
cette année et la partie importante de celle-ci
c'est à ce moment-là que nous avons hérité d'un
Bim et l'interface AIS Bim ont été
développé le cadre contractuel
le cadre est qu'il y a un projet D au
en haut pour construire cette arnaque et puis euh
l'exploiter et l'entretenir sous le
projet DED entre transport pour Nouveau
Galles du Sud et West Conex, il y a un DN
DED West se connecte et le DNC
Constructeurs, ils sont un consortium à trois
consortiums distincts, en fait quatre par le
le moment où tu amènes Rosel et à droite
côté main, il y a un acte et un
l'acte d'interface se trouve en dessous de l'acte DNC
et l'onm acte euh et c'est légalement
contraignant euh mais c'est là que nous partageons
informations avec la DNC que nous leur donnons
quelques informations sur la façon de construire euh
plans de contrôle de la circulation, réponse instantanée
procédures qu'ils intègrent au système
alors nous devons reproduire cela dans
système de gestion rendu au L&M
manuel c'est comme un pied gauche pied droit
tape step euh mais qu'est-ce qui est important à
je sais que c'est l'obligation du DNC de
construire le Bim et ce n'était qu'un DNC
obligation de construire le Bim pour scène
trois pour que vous puissiez imaginer quand la portée
était en cours de développement pour les étapes un et 2
ouverture en 2019 probablement cinq ou six
années à l'avance, la portée que nous appelons
c'est le swtc qui a été développé et Bim
c'était un Bim, c'était comme une bulle de pensée
quelque part sur la piste donc
étapes un et deux, nous n'avons pas de Bim
mais pour la troisième étape, le DNC a dû
fournir un Bim dans le cadre de leur remise
pourtant, sous l'ancien acte M, nous n'avons pas
obligation même de reconnaître
ça aurait été un peu petit
petite ville en pensant alors nous, euh, nous sommes allés
sur ce voyage en termes de Voyage
de um des actifs que nous utilisons Maximo le M4
élargir la section ou l'Ouest, il y a juste
moins de 5 000 actifs pour le M4 Est en
Juillet 2019 40 000 actifs
euh le M5 Est 15 000 atouts le M8
50 000 actifs et le lien qui est le
Bim build dont nous avons hérité 62 ou
gardien ou intendant de 62 000
actifs, je ne pourrais pas citer le chiffre que
arrivent à bord donc quelque part dans le
commande de 170 000 actifs que nous gérons
à l'intérieur à l'intérieur
Maximo euh on y va c'est vraiment
ça fait réfléchir, c'est le Bim pour
Rosel
échange c'est un Spaghetti Junction
entièrement construit
sous terre et cela va s'ouvrir
plus tard cette année, normalement quelque part
fin novembre début décembre
probablement un cadeau de Noël pour le
les gens de Sydney et ça s'est retiré
de la
Bim c'est assez euh ça a l'air très
compliqué et l'une des choses qui
nous faisons en ce moment c'est DEC
compliquer le fait que c'est toujours un tunnel
il a encore des passages transversaux il a encore
qualité de l'air mais je dois les trouver
choses et marcher à travers 160 m de long
croix
les passages vont demander un peu de travail
mais il y a deux itinéraires de voyage principaux
et il y a un certain nombre de rampes entre les deux
et il existe un moyen très simple d'ouvrir
et nos fermetures pour cette chose donc ça
ça se profile très très
gros j'ai mis tout ça en terme de
contexte sur le nombre d’actifs qui
nous avons ce que nous avons construit comment
nous avons fait ce voyage le fait que
Bim n'était pas une exigence et nous ne l'avons pas non plus
un Bim pour les étapes un et
deux mais nous avons construit cet atout
système d'information Maximo um le client
est propriétaire du système, le client sera propriétaire du
licence à la fin de notre mandat euh
mais nous l'avons construit à travers une portée mais nous'
nous avons créé de l'intelligence grâce à
nous mettre au défi et je relève
quelques mots d'asa sur la création d'un plan
et expérimenter et je dirai ça
nous l'avons fait plusieurs fois dans notre
voyage, nous avons donc fait appel à une société appelée
Clara nous utilisons IBM Maximo Clara a été notre
notre partenaire aujourd'hui où nous utilisons également
une entreprise maintenant appelée cice euh parce que
il y a tellement de travail à faire
je partage une des choses et je la mets dedans
audacieux ici, c'est important aussi, c'est ça
nous avons le système de contrôle le
omcs est la langue locale du contrôle
Le système est également interfacé à notre
AOS a obtenu 312 volts de relevés de compteurs
heures de vibration, nous faisons un peu de
maintenance prédictive euh euh prédictive
Travailler dans
Maximo trois disciplines définies suis
civil et péage 23 éléments 103 après
100 50 plus classes d'actifs mentionnées
avant d'avoir 170 000 actifs répartis
les les cinq étapes 70 000 en étape
trois et euh dans le Bim cinq données majeures
téléchargements au cours de The Last 5
Des années euh et une génération de noms unique
nous avons trois environnements pour Maximo
euh, nous utilisons la mobilité Easy Max et nous avons
j'ai environ 200 utilisateurs, et il y en aurait
être cinq licences administratives et le
les autres sont normaux tous les jours
utilisateurs
prédominant
techniciens donc en termes de ce voyage
sur un
page c'est l'activité de brainstorming
au tout début, nous avons un faisceau de
DNC, comment allons-nous l'utiliser, n'est-ce pas ?
il faut utiliser
nous sommes en train de former une opinion selon laquelle
nous rendrons efficaces et plus intelligents
plus rapide
plus précis, c'est le tout premier atelier
où nous où nous mettons notre concept sur un tableau blanc
autour du Bim créer à nouveau un plan et
l'expérience n'était pas parfaite, euh, certains des
dans le swtc certains des outs Kobe et
certaines choses il y avait certaines choses
mais ce que je dirais du tout au tout
au départ, nous avons commencé à réfléchir à partir d'un
technicien, nous avons pensé qui était l'utilisateur final
parce que si l'utilisateur final peut bien l'utiliser
cela va aider le gestionnaire d'actifs à
l'avant donc dès le tout début
première séance avec toute la technique
les gens dans la chambre, nous avions aussi un
technicien en cela
chambre parce que c'étaient eux qui
je vais utiliser le faisceau au mieux
prestation disponible et qui devait être
efficace et
en sécurité encore euh tableau blanc euh quoi
est devenu le prochain
faites glisser de sorte que sur le côté gauche se trouve le
DNC euh
création et sur le côté droit se trouve
est la pièce sur le sur le sur le
côté gauche ce que nous avons généralement
il y a trois points fondamentaux ou ou
éléments du Bim que nous utilisons
nous avons utilisé le modèle fédéré
nous avons utilisé les attributs des actifs et
le euh le modèle d'information le le
modèle d'informations sur le projet qui se trouve dans
le Bim à droite du
chose fondamentale ici en ce moment
c'est qu'il amène Maximo Maximo a un
interface directe avec le Bim vous pouvez
entrez virtuellement dans le Bim et vous
pouvez appuyer sur un appareil et vous pouvez choisir
actifs euh et faire des ordres de travail dans dans un
concept euh, je veux aussi que NE reconnaisse
dbm vercon, ils ont bien fonctionné et et
et en étroite collaboration avec nous et et fait quelques
financement sur ce prototype euh en termes de
faisant intervenir euh Forge qui est le spectateur
de la
modèle voici un petit exemple du
modèle lui-même euh et je pourrais répondre
parlons-en un peu, nous avons utilisé
un modèle fédéré réduit à construire
l'interface Bim AIS et la balanceb
le modèle fédérateur doit exister de manière transparente
dans l'AOS euh Maximo qui est affiché
sur le
laissé euh tous les actifs maintenables doivent être
identifié entre le modèle et l'AOS donc
il doit y avoir une convention unique
lien euh et fonctionnalités de base très basiques
que nous intégrons en termes d'ordre de travail
et le bon de travail de vérification de demande de service est
histoire pour qu'un technicien puisse entrer
une pièce et ils peuvent cliquer sur un actif
grâce au Bim ils peuvent aller au maximum
et ils peuvent trouver ce qu'ils sont, ce qu'ils sont
prêt à réaliser le travail dans lequel se trouve l'ORD
devant eux, ce que travaillent les cinq derniers
les commandes ressemblent à l'état
l'historique sur les données mais en apportant
en d'autre
des systèmes comme notre ICS où l'onm
le manuel réside actuellement auquel ils peuvent accéder
tous les rapports de conception tous les OEM
recommandations euh tous les dessins tous
de nos déclarations de méthodes de travail à venir
et et ayez-le devant eux plutôt
que d'utiliser plusieurs systèmes dans le
Téléchargement du dépôt
le principe de base est que le plus
désolé, le principe de base est que
le modèle reste le modèle le modèle B
c'est-à-dire et l'AOS reste l'AOS mais
ils
lié certaines des fonctionnalités avancées de
ingénierie numérique de en Atout
Gestion euh reporting graphique donc
quand nous commençons à construire une évaluation de l'état
l'évaluation de l'état peut être superposée et
visiblement vu donc les gestionnaires d'actifs maintenant nous avons
J'ai les données des techniciens, c'est
fiable et pertinent et récent mais
les gestionnaires d'actifs peuvent désormais commencer à faire
prendre des décisions sur les mouvements et ils peuvent
voir les choses dans des couleurs très très simples
des schémas que vous connaissez sous le nom de y a-t-il un
une rangée complète de périphériques a échoué depuis
un suivi vibratoire on peut voir des choses
émergeant donc nous commençons à jouer
autour de ce que la condition serait
on dirait dans le dans le Bim sur sur dans
termes de superpositions qui joueront ensuite
dans l'espace du gestionnaire d'actifs pour commencer
modéliser euh et gérer les Opex et
dépenses d'investissement, je pensais que j'aurais pu
pour vous donner une démo en direct mais ce que je vais
ce que je fais, c'est que je mets mes e-mails ici et pour
ceux qui sont intéressés, tous ceux qui sont
intéressé, envoie-moi un e-mail ou
par l'intermédiaire de Richard et nous allons organiser
une séance avec le modèle vivant car
c'est très impressionnant mais c'est un peu
un peu capricieux de mettre un écran dans
devant vous tous
aujourd'hui donc c'est vraiment ça euh quoi
Je dirais que c'est c'est c'est un prototype
nous ne l'utilisons pas complètement maintenant
nous luttons avec les mérites de
construire une poutre rétrospectivement pour
étapes un et deux de chaque côté
euh, nous travaillons sur quelques appels d'offres
pour le moment, euh, où ce serait
incroyablement important alors ne le dis pas
le monde, euh, qui est dans notre poche
donc euh, le prototype, le concept a été
prouvé, euh, nous y avons beaucoup réfléchi, nous
j'y ai pensé dès le début
application fondamentale avec le
technicien à comment ça fonctionnerait euh et
tout ce que nous pouvons voir, c'est que ça va
créer des gains d'efficacité dans l'exécution des tâches
qu'il s'agisse d'un technicien, d'un civil ou d'un
un monteur mécanique possède tous les
informations devant eux, mais le
les informations deviennent alors plus fiables
comme je l'ai dit, pertinent euh, la qualité du
données transmises pour l'actif
les managers donc c'est là que nous en sommes, euh
ça a été un peu un voyage merci
pour ton temps et pour écouter ça
[Applaudissements]
le matin oui, c'est toujours très impressionnant
il y a des questions
tous très timides ce matin l'année dernière nous
j'ai commencé avec ACDC c'est peut-être pour ça
Élène
question puis-je voir une autre question
ici
ouais, euh, est-ce que ton client le sait
à ce sujet et que pense votre client
penses-y
tout cela est très très très important, euh
question, notre client a financé une partie de
le développement de cette um application
mais le rythme de l'Ouest nous connecte, nous le mettons
sur la glace, il est assis sur le côté
moment simplement parce que
euh, où nous avons assez de travail sur notre
plaque pour construire l’AOS fondamental à
le moment et le rythme de ces deux
les actifs arrivent dans l'énormité d'un
Le client a dit : regarde, nous aimons le
idée mais nous voulons que vous obteniez les bases
c'est vrai donc c'est euh je pense que c'est le
la langue que nous utilisons, c'est une femme enceinte
pause pour le moment
euh, j'aimerais penser que nous y investirons
parce qu'il nous reste encore quelques années
sur notre
à terme, les choses vont se stabiliser, mais les deux
les actifs de stade 3a et 3B ont tous deux
je me suis manifesté trois mois et ça fait
un morceau de préparation ici et puis il y a
évidemment beaucoup d'apprentissage donc notre
les clients nous ont demandé très gentiment, pouvez-vous
reste assis là pour le moment, euh mais
ils savent de quoi il est capable
je le fais et pour être tout à fait honnête
nous commençons à voir les avantages
nous-mêmes que le client adhèrera
ils n'auront peut-être pas à financer, mais nous pouvons
voir le bénéfice nous-mêmes dans certains coûts S
des économies, donc euh, ils sont le seul client
que nous n'avons pas montré ça à
quelqu'un d'autre pour l'instant mais notre client
sur West Conect, c'est transurbain ouais et
c'est donc une question très importante
parce que c'est comme ça que nous l'avons construit l'année dernière
jusqu'en 2023, lorsque le nouvel actif est arrivé et
alors il a juste été mis sur la glace pendant un
petit
peu
euh, il a été financé en quatre parties ouais donc
le client a mis de l'argent, nous en avons mis
de l'argent en Clarita et
dbm a également mis de l'argent parce qu'ils sont
vendant évidemment les vertus de aussi
et je parle mais pour le moment c'est tout
n'est pas allé plus loin que l'Ouest
connectez-vous et ils, je dirais que nous sommes
c'est sur la touche pour le moment
c'est juste sur la touche pour rester au chaud
nous ouvrons ce nouvel actif à la fin de
l'année où nous avons eu deux ans de plus pour
stabiliser et et et construire et je je
j'aimerais penser que nous
aurez-vous besoin de compétences spécifiques
pour mettre en œuvre le faisceau ou l'op pour
faisceau, nous avons dû faire appel à des experts
nous avons un expert en ingénierie numérique, euh
dans nos rangs, mais c'est un homme très intelligent
praticien aussi bien et autant qu'il est
il est techniquement capable, il a aussi
le il a fondamentalement été sur le
des outils pour commencer, c'est ce qu'il pense
est au niveau Bim le niveau de l'actif mais
il réfléchit également à la façon dont
travail de technicien mais nous avons dû compter
beaucoup sur dbm et cl sur le
voyage merci beaucoup c'est très
impressionnant et un grand atout pour l’AIS
Réseau, vous voyez, nous avons un excellent réseau
tout le monde en a parlé pour gagner le projet
à l'avenir, nous aurons besoin de
expertise que nous explorons nous avons
facteurs de différenciation pour que réellement
un merci beaucoup
alors maintenant je suis très heureux d'appeler
Jette donc Ganette va bien, elle le fera
se présente et je suis très heureux que
elle pourrait venir parce que Meridium en est un
de nos clients et je pense que c'est
important quand on parle d’opérationnel
l'excellence que nous entendons de nos clients et
ESG, avouons-le lorsque vous opérez
et maintenir l'ESG d'une entreprise est en quelque sorte
c'est pénible désolé FR mais tu dois le faire
et ça change et maintenant c'est le
critère numéro un et euh méridium
est vraiment très expert en la matière
un avion d'entreprise très réussi expliquera
et je pense que c'est très important pour
pour nous d'écouter, écoutez ça parce que
nous devons changer notre état d'esprit et le
notre façon de travailler, alors merci beaucoup, merci
toi de m'avoir reçu ce matin euh et euh
oui, nous sommes très concentrés sur
enjeux de gouvernance sociale environnementale
et et et comment les gérer et de
bien sûr, euh, pour avoir un impact quand un
impact positif lorsque nous investissons dans
les atouts, euh, et bien, parlons-en
euh donc par euh en présentant Meridiam I
et et et et notre
durabilité euh approche euh
engagements et obligations, euh, j'étais
en espérant, euh, faire la lumière sur pourquoi
nous sommes si exigeants et pourquoi nous attendons
nos partenaires et prestataires de services
être aussi impliqué que nous dans le
gérer ces problèmes et et et
générer des impacts positifs et j'aime
ce que M. Ure a dit, nous voulons être ceux-là
l'autre suivra ou voudra suivre
euh donc c'est pour ça que nous attendons
nos atouts doivent offrir tellement de choses
euh tellement d'impact euh donc en gros nous sommes
conduit par euh et peut-être que je vais juste y aller
à travers la présentation de maman
en soi donc nous sommes un investissement privé
fonds euh nous nous concentrons sur les infrastructures euh
et nous verrons les trois principaux euh euh
secteurs d'activités euh nous euh nous étions
créé en 2005 euh et à partir du
début euh ESG environnemental social
et les questions de gouvernance étaient au premier plan
le cœur de notre
préoccupations euh alors euh nous j'ai toujours
été euh euh impliqué dans ou ou ou euh
je travaille sur la définition des procédures et
des processus qui, euh, pourraient
aborder ces problèmes, euh, mais plus encore
récemment, nous avons bien sûr augmenté notre
euh actions euh envers euh ce particulier
objectifs donc nous en avons plus de 100 20 euh
projet ou actifs dans le portefeuille à
le moment ou en développement et nous sommes
lever de nouveaux fonds euh chaque année alors
Bien sûr, ce nombre va augmenter
euh comme vous pouvez le voir, nous sommes très dispersés
euh dans le monde entier aussi bien que toi
sont bien sûr euh mais moins en Asie
ou en Australie mais euh vraiment, euh
Europe euh Amérique du Nord et un peu de
L'Amérique du Sud aussi euh et et nous euh
nous nous sommes également développés en Afrique depuis
En 2015, nous étions, euh, presque le
premier fonds privé à être impliqué dans
euh Actifs en public euh infrastructure en
Afrique euh nous, nous sommes assez fiers de
le fait que nous sommes, euh, nous avons euh 48
nationalités dans nos bureaux
11 bureaux partout dans le monde euh nous
appelons-nous comme presque les États-Unis
Nations, euh, je pensais que j'étais vraiment exotique
tu sais, je viens de Montréal euh mais je
ce n'était pas euh il y avait d'autres Canadiens
là à Kers euh et il y avait comme
tu connais plus de gens exotiques que
moi euh mais euh mais tu sais dire que c'est
c'est juste un autre exemple de la façon dont
encastrés nous sommes dans les territoires ou dans
l'environnement dans lequel nous investissons et
où nous développons des projets et c'est
aussi un bon exemple de notre approche dans
en général donc nous voulons être proches des gens
nous voulons comprendre quelle est la réalité
les problèmes sont et comment les résoudre quand
nous développons des projets quand nous euh même
choisir ou ou sélectionner un investissement
opportunités et cela vient du
des équipes qui sont euh sur les marchés et dans
les territoires où nous euh
investir donc ce sont trois secteurs de
des activités donc bien sûr durables
La mobilité que tu es probablement plus euh
je connais bien sûr euh et nous avons
j'ai travaillé avec Isis euh pour toi
je le sais depuis longtemps et euh et de
cours sur de nombreux projets différents euh
nous sommes également impliqués dans des activités critiques
Services publics euh comme vous pouvez le voir
c'est euh euh ce sont toutes sortes de euh
les bâtiments publics euh ça va
fournir les services essentiels mais aussi
euh nous avons beaucoup de réseaux de fibre d'eau
et de l'eau euh Services des eaux usées euh de
Bien sûr, tout le monde sait que maintenant nous avons
euh, nous sommes l'un des principaux sh
actionnaires de su France um et de
cours Solutions innovantes bas carbone
donc cela inclut tout ce qui concerne
à euh la transition énergétique et euh et même
PME et et et autres euh Technologies
alors quelle est notre approche euh donc chaque fois que je
Je suppose que tout le monde sait ce que dit l'ONU
les ODD sont le développement durable de l'ONU
objectifs qui est un ensemble de 17 objectifs durables
les objectifs de développement, euh, c'étaient euh, allons-y
dis que c'est un cadre ou euh ouais un
cadre qui a été développé et et et
approuvé par euh par tous euh euh pays euh
comme étant le moyen le plus efficace de
exprimer et et expliquer et et Set euh
euh objectifs euh par rapport à ce qui est nécessaire pour euh
pour euh, garantir que notre monde restera
et que nous allons euh nous pourrons
continuer à vivre euh dans un dans un
environnement approprié euh nous euh en 2019
nous sommes devenus une Miss de la société, ce qui est euh la
l'équivalent d'un avantage pour une société si
euh si c'est euh ça
euh, ce nom est plus familier, euh, alors
et c'est ça c'était pour nous le meilleur euh
euh, le meilleur moment pour peut-être officialiser notre
stratégie de durabilité et nous avons décidé
puis utiliser les ODD les plus pertinents
pour Meridiam, euh, pour définir ces cinq
les piliers sont euh le genre
une sorte de moteur de ce que nous voulions
fais et euh pour chaque pilier euh nous avons euh
développé des objectifs de mission que nous
moniteur que nous mesurons chaque année euh nous avons
euh, je viens juste de terminer une période de trois ans
de nos premiers objectifs de mission et nous
travaillons sur notre nouvelle mission
objectifs donc tout ce que nous faisons est
euh en référence à ces cinq piliers
et le système de développement durable
les objectifs et la mission
objectifs, cela ne veut pas dire que nous
ne frappe pas les autres, euh durable
objectifs de développement avec nos atouts c'est
juste que c'est euh notre objectif
je voulais euh à utiliser pour euh
pour notre entreprise et pour surveiller nos
performance alors quand quand je dis que nous
surveiller les performances, ce qui signifie que nous
besoin de la contribution de tous les actifs euh
pour parvenir à réaliser ces missions
objectifs et je vais vous montrer comment nous
mesurer cela et nous collectons des données pour
euh pour être sûr qu'on est à droite
suivre, c'est aussi euh quelque chose qui
c'est, euh, que je voulais te montrer parce que c'est
explique également le contexte dans lequel nous
maintenant investir et développer des projets et ce
est aussi
euh, je pense que c'est une réalité pour toi, euh, nous l'avons
euh différent, euh différents engagements
et euh réglementaire
obligations euh et bien sûr euh tout
sortes d'analyses comparatives que nous faisons, mais
en fin de compte, cela se reflète dans la façon dont
nous faisons des affaires et ce que nous attendons de
nos fesses de nos actifs parce que c'est
tout sur les activités que nous faisons pour que
ça veut dire les investissements que nous faisons euh
le et et tout ce que vous voyez ici est
à propos de euh, c'est une question de responsabilité et
transparence, vous devez donc dire ce que vous
fais et fais ce que tu dis et pour le
transparence, ici, c'est comme ça
engagement formel alors je l'ai dit, miss 2019
B Corp euh selon le le
Américain euh cadre euh c'est arrivé
dans
euh nous avons enam nous aimons les acronymes ici euh
donc enam est un gestionnaire d'actifs net zéro donc
c'est un engagement envers, euh, à être carbone
neutre avec tous nos fonds scope un deux
et trois d'ici 2050, donc c'est énorme
engagement et bien sûr nous avons deux
deux
2030 U seuil que nous avons également
pour rencontrer euh le tcfd est le groupe de travail
sur euh clim euh sur le carbone lié
La divulgation financière et celle de la nature
arrive et sera euh signataire de
que l'année prochaine et nous pourrons ou
nous devons nous préparer à euh à à euh à à
divulguer et et rendre publics nos
rapport afin que tous ces engagements soient
sur la façon dont nous faisons des affaires et comment nous
gérer nos actifs comment nous y investissons
comment ils sont développés
à quels critères ils répondront et
quels objectifs ils pourront atteindre euh
pour répondre également aux exigences réglementaires
les obligations sont extrêmement strictes
aujourd'hui et ils vont juste être
augmente et je pense que certains de vos
les actifs en Europe seront touchés par le csrd
qui est l'entreprise
durable euh reporting divulgation
directive, je suis désolé, il y en a tellement, euh
mais c'est euh tu sais tout sur euh euh
reportage sur le le le le Dual
matérialité de euh de votre projet et
les impacts que cela aura sur le
l'environnement et les impacts de
environnement sur vos actifs donc tout cela
les choses sont très importantes quand je dis
que nous euh tu sais nous avons nous nous attendons
de nos partenaires et de notre service
prestataires beaucoup d'implication et beaucoup
d'informations provenant d'eux et
des idées aussi, euh, tout est question d'être
euh
Innovant et pour faire tout cela et pour
mesurer nos performances, nous utilisons euh
différents outils dont nous disposons
contribué à développer euh en interne et
avec aussi avec euh externe
experts donc le premier est simple
c'est juste beaucoup de couleur, je pensais
ça, ça aurait l'air sympa ici mais euh
en gros, c'est la durabilité
plateforme de mesure d'impact simple euh
c'est un outil c'est un outil en ligne
questionnaire envoyé chaque année à
tous les atouts pour que vous puissiez certains d'entre vous
aurait pu être impliqué ou reçu
un questionnaire c'est une c'est une une
plateforme et avec les données
qu'on collectionne on euh on a des repères
et et et et pour comparer les
performance de chaque actif sur chaque
indicateur ou ou certains indicateurs et que
euh nous permet de mesurer la contribution
des atouts pour euh le durable
objectifs de développement, c'est ainsi que nous pouvons
en fait, identifiez, euh, vous connaissez le potentiel
améliorations que nous pouvons voir euh avec un
un actif spécifique euh sur un euh spécifique
sujet, nous avons aussi euh euh euh des outils pour
euh tu sais à cause du changement climatique
euh euh problèmes liés euh tellement carbone
empreinte bien sur mais Kara qui est une
un outil intégré euh comme une fonctionnalité ou
une euh euh euh euh une méthodologie spécifique
mesurer la température des actifs et
température des fonds euh euh dans
par rapport à une trajectoire à deux degrés,
est un outil très puissant car il donne
vous comparez la température des actifs
vers une trajectoire 2° et une fois que tu sais
ça, tu ne peux pas l'oublier d'abord et tu
Je ne peux pas le cacher parce que tu tu tu tu
tu dois réagir tu dois faire
quelque chose pour réduire le
la température des actifs afin que
signifie réduire l’empreinte carbone et
avec tous ces outils
euh nous euh nous développons des plans d'action pour
chaque atout et nous verrons ce que quoi
ces actifs le font, comment pouvons-nous inclure tous
c'est euh ces processus ou procédures Pro
au sein de notre um, notre processus d'investissement et
et et le processus de gestion des actifs
cela fait beaucoup de texte, vous n'êtes pas obligé
lis-le, ne t'inquiète pas, c'est juste pour
vous montrer que les équipes d'investissement de
meridiam doit être tu sais directement ou
très déterminé à gérer les questions ESG
et en s'assurant que chaque actif sera
livrer
ODD et c'est à ce moment-là qu'ils s'engageront
avec euh les équipes de conception, vous les gars et
et et et aussi pendant euh euh le
la période de fonctionnement euh pour voir comment
pour améliorer au mieux les atouts et c'est un
une exigence pour chaque euh investissement
les équipes et euh tu sais quand elles se rencontrent
gestion pour ou ou ou investissement
commissions, ils doivent expliquer ce que
ils font pour y parvenir
objectifs spécifiques donc si nous regardons
quelques études de cas I I J'ai pris quelques notes
parce que euh je je je sais que tu les connais
euh des projets par cœur euh et je ne l'ai pas fait
je veux oublier quelque chose alors euh alors toi
Je n'ai ni scut, ce qui est une voie à suivre, euh a
partie nord de euh Port Portugal euh et
euh près, ça vient de près de la frontière de
L'Espagne à VCU euh plus au sud euh
donc Isis était U, euh depuis le début
partenaire sur ce euh sur ce projet et
euh tu sais nous nous nous euh euh nous nous avons
développé ce projet puisque euh je ne le suis pas
si je ne me trompe pas, c'est 200 euh
c'est ça, il a été construit
2013 ouais désolé et maman est devenue unique euh
Euh, actionnaire de
2016 euh, que s'est-il passé avec l'actif
et et moi, nous en avons sélectionné quelques-uns
réussite euh encore une fois en utilisant notre outil
simple où nous pouvons réellement comparer
d'une année sur l'autre quoi euh
Des améliorations se sont produites et
euh et ça nous aide aussi à identifier
domaines dans lesquels nous devons encore améliorer
notre
performance et euh nous pour que vous puissiez voir
que nous nous avons fait euh tu sais avec euh avec
nos partenaires euh beaucoup de bonnes choses nous
panneaux solaires installés euh nous étions euh
impliqué dans euh dans Eco Driving Pro euh
les programmes de formation euh et ce qui est prévu
dans un futur très proche, c'est euh euh
tu en sais plus sur la plantation d'espèces naturelles
autour de ou dans l'emprise
et et autour du le le projet
euh et c'est euh par exemple pour euh pour
empêcher la propagation des incendies de forêt et
bien sûr, tu sais, continue à t'améliorer
la sécurité sur l'autoroute maintenant nous l'avons
un autre euh vite une autre étude de cas
qui est A5 Autriche euh et encore nous euh
partenaire très tôt sur ce projet euh
et c'est une autoroute très importante euh euh
parce que ça soulage les locaux
les embouteillages euh dans les villes sont dans
la zone de l'autoroute et euh
encore une fois, nous utilisons un outil simple pour
identifier quoi avec euh de bonnes actions
ont été mis en œuvre et euh, qu'est-ce qui peut
continue, je suis désolé, quelque chose
c'est arrivé avec ma présentation, ma
présentation ils sont, ils ne sont pas alignés
aligné mais euh juste pour te parler
le Programme d'action pour la biodiversité qui est
euh ça se passe et qui a été euh un vrai
euh, passion pour les gens qui travaillent sur le
actifs aujourd'hui et et sur cet actif aujourd'hui
euh et euh, c'est un énorme programme
et c'est ça continue euh euh toi
je sais pour les prochaines années euh et plus encore
récemment euh tu connais d'autres majors euh
des mesures ont été prises euh et euh nous l'étions
j'ai dit ça aux moutons qui sont euh
fait déjà partie d'un programme de pâturage, le
les moutons euh responsables de la tonte du
loi en gros, euh, nous avons ajouté deux ânes
apparemment, ils aident parce qu'ils mangent
ce que les moutons ne font pas et ils le font
je suis sûr qu'il n'y a pas d'intrus
le site donc euh donc toutes ces bonnes choses
se produisent et cela fait partie du
le travail que nous attendons des personnes qui travaillent
sur le terrain, euh, en opération et
entretenir nos actifs euh et concevoir
eux, donc c'est l'innovation, c'est euh tu sais
sortir des sentiers battus également et
planifier le
futur oui merci beaucoupette avait
la chance de visiter l'Australien
projet et Rudolph le directeur général
de l'entreprise est là pour la première
la fois où j'ai visité une autoroute et nous ne l'avons pas fait
voir l'autoroute nous avons vu un lac nous avons vu
Animal Crossing, nous avons vu des fermes solaires mais
la Moto très vite pour revenir donc
c'est vraiment impressionnant et merci
beaucoup pour pour pour pour pour cette Jette
parce que tu es vraiment à la limite et dedans
mon avis et bien quand quand tu veux
s'associer avec quelqu'un, c'est un must
ce n'est plus la cerise sur le gâteau
gâteau c'est un gâteau en soi et dans le
dans les prochaines années, tous les fonds seront demandés
Alors innovons, capitalisons
utilisons notre réseau dans les limites pour
fournir plus de valeur, donc je suis très
impressionné et ce n'est pas qu'un souhait euh
tu me montres une présentation plus détaillée
d'un outil d'évaluation simple super
impressionnant tu m'as même dit que tu l'étais peut-être
je planifie bien, ça se passe, c'est
ça se passe ouais nous le commercialisons
nous avons créé une société distincte pour
et bien peut-être pour répandre le bien
actualités et de les relier à d'autres
exigences euh telles que le pi le sfdr
et tous ces bons acronymes alors peut-être que toi
J'ai un client ici dans la salle aussi
il y a des questions pour
Janette bien très clair je regarde la France
parce que d'accord
un
euh merci Jette, très intéressant
question tu as dit que l'outil K
vous utilisez pour mesurer la température de
le projet à
en terminant, comment allez-vous parce que c'est un
question que nous nous posons, comment faire
vous mesurez quelle est votre ligne de base vous vous
vous sécurisez un projet vous y investissez
quelle est la base de référence prenez-vous
le projet tel qu'il serait sans votre
intervention prenez-vous le projet
que tu as déjà, tu peux déjà avoir
amélioré, quelle est votre philosophie à ce sujet
euh, Kiar travaille sur le fait qu'il y a un
le budget pour le carbone est déjà utilisé
une géographie spécifique et puis vous
compare euh si tu en ajoutes un autre
infrastructure et c'est fait pour
infrastructure parce que c'est ça c'est ça
existait mais euh pour peut-être d'autres types de
euh, un atout, maintenant, ce que nous avons apporté
c'est, tu le sais, dépensé pour euh
infrastructure donc chaque infrastructure
que vous ajoutez enlèvera
le budget dont vous disposez et
et puis tu sais, tu te rapproches et
plus proche de ne pas pouvoir euh ou de
respecter votre trajectoire de deux diplômes
donc c'est un peu comme ça que ça marche
donc ce n'est pas grave si nous ne le faisons pas
c'est plus ce qui se passe si tu
savoir quand on mesure les évités
les émissions par exemple ou euh ou le
l'empreinte carbone en général c'est toujours
euh par rapport à une ligne de base qui est euh la
actuel
situation et c'est basé sur la
utilisations du du du
atout merci donc pour la dernière
présentation encore merci beaucoup
muchette pour la dernière présentation
ouais, de ce premier panneau que j'aime appeler
Elen prononce à la française et et
Andy, euh, je les ai rencontrés pour la première fois
il y a un an, lors de ma visite au M25 et pour
moi euh M25 était un vaisseau spatial parce que donc
différent du projet très
projet compliqué très industrialisé
beaucoup de pression et généralement un projet
après un deux trois ans est stabilisé
Je suppose que le tien ne se stabilisera jamais.
Toujours un nouveau défi et donc je suis
très heureux que vous puissiez présenter votre
projet car encore une fois nous avons beaucoup à faire
apprendre de
ça va, euh, un peu de contexte pour commencer
euh et assez brièvement donc projet M25 euh
en général, nous sommes impliqués dans les deux parties
de concession et
opérateur euh et nous gérons le contrat
au nom de la nation
les autoroutes euh nous nous occupons de la gestion des actifs
et le risque d'investissement, euh, pour le
les renouvellements euh et ensuite nous devons terminer
les opérations quotidiennes et l'ensemble
la chose est enveloppée dans ce qui est
effectivement un
forfaitaire donc c'est un peu comme ça qu'egis obtient
impliqué euh les différentes parties du
contrat sont la conception et la construction qui
c'est le bouchon
dépenser euh et tout a été fait euh tôt
dans le contrat pour le
Les Jeux olympiques et puis euh nos principales activités
pour le moment, c'est le cycle de vie
renouvellements, euh, qui est une somme forfaitaire effective
à
2039 euh on fait des améliorations sur le
réseau au nom des autorités nationales
autoroutes qui qui finance
ceux-là et euh nous exploitons et entretenons le
réseau qui est celui d'Andy
travail donc un peu à l'échelle de l'échelle de
ce projet prend un peu de temps
je comprends donc 440 kilomètres donc
c'est des kilomètres de voies du réseau routier
avec le M25, c'est euh moins de la moitié de
dont nous sommes responsables
maintenir ce que nous appelons les talons et
Queue euh donc ça pourrait être euh l'a23
qui est effectivement High Street à travers
un village euh vers euh le M4 surélevé qui
est un très vieux
structure à travers la banlieue de Londres, je
je suppose que nous avons une gamme complète
d'actifs et de problèmes et il y a
quelques faits et chiffres supplémentaires
voilà donc nous en avons fini
140 000 actifs 750 ponts euh et nous
J'ai le Q2 donc ce contrat a été signé
dans
2009 euh et nous en avons eu des centaines
des gens que nous avons affrontés quand nous
signé le contrat donc nous avons beaucoup
les gens les gens qui travaillent pour nous qui ont
toujours travaillé sur le
M25 de euh enfant à adulte donc euh
ça fait partie de ce que nous avons pris, euh et
andy en parlera un peu plus
plus tard ok merci euh Elena bien
matin euh club des opérateurs merci à
egis de m'avoir invité euh c'est vrai je veux
partage quelques photos avec vous en premier
tout ce qu'il dit, un an sur le M25, cela pourrait
en fait, ce sera un jour, euh, pour être honnête
aussi, donc euh, côté gauche, là, euh
les photos sont un peu granuleuses mais
ce que vous pouvez voir, c'est de la pastèque partout
le euh le réseau qui s'est produit dans le
mi-août, euh cette année, j'ai essayé
ou j'avais l'intention d'apprendre le français
mot pour pastèque pour t'impressionner mais je
euh, je n'ai pas réussi à le faire hier soir mais je le ferai
demande à Richard de me dire ce que c'est, euh
plus tard, euh, au milieu, tu as
J'ai le changement climatique, euh, les manifestants que nous avions
quelques visiteurs sur le M25 en octobre
et en novembre de l'année dernière, ils ont attaché
se rendre au pont QE2 à Dartford
ainsi que de nombreux autres portiques aux alentours
le euh le réseau et c'est vraiment
important parce que je pense que om andm omm est
c'est vraiment dur, n'est-ce pas, mais nous y sommes presque
je tends un miroir à la société
les défis que nous voyons en cas de pandémie
changement climatique, ils se manifestent
non seulement dans les actifs que nous gérons dans
les défis mais aussi des choses comme ça
euh aussi euh la troisième photo euh
c'était un portique, euh, il y avait une grue
voyageant à l'arrière d'un camion, nous
je ne sais pas vraiment ce qui s'est passé mais le
la grue a soulevé et traîné notre G
euh, avec ça, c'est arrivé en juin, euh
cette année et sur le côté droit euh
ces photos viennent d'un circuit fermé
euh la télé donc tu ne peux pas les voir très bien si
tu regardes en haut dans ce cercle rouge
vous pouvez presque voir comme une sorte de
un doigt pointé vers le bas, c'est juste dedans
sorte d'Ombre à contre-courant de la lumière de
le tunnel qui est un luminaire
Lumin a qui pend à la couronne
du euh du tunnel de Dartford qui euh
le mécanisme a échoué, les fixations ont échoué
il a ensuite été heurté par un camion et le Lumin
puis je suis tombé sur la route en contrebas
Heureusement, personne n'a été blessé
nous a démontré les risques liés au traitement
avec euh un atout vieillissant alors quand tu
réfléchis en quelque sorte à toi-même, pourquoi avons-nous besoin
excellence opérationnelle pourquoi pourquoi s'embêter
même si ça a l'air d'être bien, euh, bien
chose que ces défis qui sont arrivés à
euh avec nous sur le M25 tous les jours
cela nous submergerait simplement de notre
l'excellence opérationnelle, nous devons apprendre
leçons que nous devons débriefer sur ces choses
nous devons continuellement nous améliorer pour répondre
les défis d'aujourd'hui et ceux
les défis se présentent de différentes manières
et les défis d'aujourd'hui seront
différent des défis en trois
ou quatre ans
le temps et nous nous trompons parfois euh
donc gérer tous les actifs que euh
Elaine, euh, a décrit ce que c'est
l'excellence opérationnelle est en réalité un
nécessité sur le M25, vous pourriez être de
je pense que c'est assez évident
Andy tu sais que tu n'as pas besoin de venir
ici dans ton costume et dis-nous que c'est
c'est bien sûr opérationnel c'est un bon
chose, c'est encore plus important sur euh sur
le M25 dans notre contrat parce que
selon que tu es heureux ou non
ce matin on pourrait dire que nous sommes
incité à faire les choses correctement si vous
marcher pendant 15 minutes comme je l'ai fait dans le
il pleut et tu te sens un peu négatif
on pourrait dire que ces choses sont
nous punir, donc la photo là-bas
le côté gauche qui est euh euh juste
au-dessus de l'un des carrefours à Junction
10 sur le
M25, euh, il y avait un euh un véhicule qui
j'ai frappé ce feu de circulation, c'est un
piéton euh passage à niveau euh et ça a été posé
dans cette position depuis trois semaines maintenant, euh
à cause de ça, nous avons pris une pénalité
parce que nous n'avions pas géré un risque sur
le réseau qu'était le passage pour piétons
obstrué par ce feu de circulation et
ça voulait dire que c'était dangereux pour quelqu'un
traverser la route alors euh qu'est-ce que ça fait
signifie bien en termes de pénalité financière
c'est ce qu'on appelle une haute priorité
défaut et quand quand nous n'atténuons pas
le danger lorsque nous ne protégeons pas le
danger, euh, nous pouvons subir une pénalité allant jusqu'à
à 2 000 par heure pour chaque heure
cet actif se trouve dans cette position euh ça
2 000 augmentations avec l'inflation chaque
année donc c'est probablement plus comme 2 et un
un demi-millier par heure maintenant qu'un seul incident
et je suis désolé pour Zavier et Carlo qui
sont nos membres du conseil d'administration d'egis, euh, ça coûte
nous a coûté près d'un million de livres dans un
pénalité et savez-vous ce qui aurait
nous a protégé ce million de livres si nous
j'avais mis quelques cônes autour et quelques
de ce ruban jaune alors nous aurions
on a vu qu'il avait géré ce danger
nous aurions alerté les gens à ce sujet
Hazard, nous n'aurions subi aucune pénalité
euh du tout maintenant c'est pour ça qu'il est opérationnel
l'excellence est si importante maintenant euh
Heureusement, c'est arrivé juste avant que je prenne
mon rôle actuel, sinon je suis probablement
j'aurais eu, euh, travaillé au cinéma
euh ici mais c'était très important et très
une leçon très importante que nous devons apprendre
et avancer euh sous opérationnel
excellence
alors, que signifie l'élément opérationnel
pour nous, eh bien, je pense que c'est vraiment tout
à propos de ce genre de personnes, euh, systèmes et
processus et données que vous pouvez probablement
mettre les systèmes soit dans euh, euh, données, soit ou
processus pour être honnête mais j'y vais
pour commencer à parler des gens alors euh toi
je connais l'excellence opérationnelle, euh, j'en ai
près de 450 personnes qui travaillent pour moi
dans le cadre de la prestation de services euh et si je
je suis allé vers eux et je leur ai dit, euh, je suis vraiment
nous allons livrer des opérationnels
l'excellence, ils pourraient en quelque sorte hocher la tête
un peu, ils pensent bien, c'est super
et tu as assisté à une belle conférence
et j'ai discuté avec des gens très intelligents
des gens et j'ai pris un bon café, mais quoi
est-ce que ça signifie pour moi quand je suis dehors
le réseau essaie de couper l'herbe
ou vider une canalisation, donc euh avec le
culture, ce que nous devions faire, c'était
Connectez cet opérationnel um Excellence
message directement aux gens euh
collègues effectuant les activités sur
la ligne de front alors nous avons trouvé
s'améliorer chaque jour et Ela l'a mentionné
plus tôt, nous avons beaucoup de collègues qui
avez travaillé dans l'entreprise ou avec le
M25 depuis ses débuts il y a 30 40 ans donc
les convaincre ou ou leur faire passer un message
autour de l’excellence opérationnelle opérationnelle
Avoir du sens pour eux est vraiment important
donc nous avons réussi à nous améliorer chaque jour, donc
sympa, gentil et simple, tout le monde
je peux comprendre ce que cela signifie
allons un peu mieux demain
apprenons quelque chose de bon ou de bon aujourd'hui
mauvais, prends ça en avant, euh, pour demain
et nous nous sommes concentrés sur trois choses que nous
concentré sur la sécurité euh observations nous
concentré sur quelque chose appelé Réseau
l'intendance et vous pensez probablement
KY, qu'est-ce qu'une gestion de réseau, je veux dire
je parle anglais, je ne le sais même pas vraiment
je sais ce que cela signifie mais vois-le, signale-le
c'est ce que cela signifie réellement, donc cela signifie
si vous êtes un entrepreneur qui cherche
drainage ou si vous êtes un entrepreneur
en regardant la végétation, vous pouvez gérer
les choses sur lesquelles on peut voir les problèmes
le réseau qui n'est pas lié à
toi, donc ce feu de circulation que j'ai montré
vous avez dit plus tôt combien de personnes ont conduit
passé, les gens m'aiment, les gens de notre
chaîne d'approvisionnement euh les gens chez nos parents
les entreprises euh nous avons tous des yeux et des oreilles
nous pouvons tous, euh, nous pouvons tous voir et signaler
défauts euh sur le réseau et le troisième
l'élément était notre euh qu'est-ce qu'on sait
comme notre défaut de catégorie un, ce sont donc
les types de défauts les plus graves qui
nous avons sur le réseau donc des choses comme
de gros nids-de-poule, euh et je les mesure
donc réseau d'observations de sécurité
gestion et euh défauts de catégorie 1
vous pouvez voir là quand nous avons lancé notre C
campagne rapportée, nous avons constaté une forte augmentation
en nombre d'intendance du réseau
observations euh qui étaient en cours
soumis une intendance du réseau si vous
je veux une définition, c'est probablement celle de
en haut à gauche, donc c'est cette philosophie de
attentionné responsable euh responsabilité de
le M25 et notre
actifs donc traitant de la première catégorie
euh défaut donc excellence opérationnelle
Je m'améliore chaque jour, très très bien, comment
est-ce que nous livrons cela, comment pouvons-nous nous assurer
que nous surveillons et mesurons, euh, comme
c'était l'une des questions qui sont venues
plus tôt, nous avons donc introduit quotidiennement
performances euh critiques donc en bas
voilà maintenant un écran qui apparaît
dans chacun de nos dépôts opérationnels
et c'est vraiment simple, c'est juste
regarde combien de défauts aviez-vous prévu
faire aujourd'hui, combien aviez-vous l'intention de faire
euh résolu aujourd'hui et ensuite combien l'ont fait
vous le faites et qu'est-ce que cela signifie si nous
je ne le ferais pas si nous en avions sept et nous seulement
en avons-nous cinq pourquoi n'en avons-nous eu que cinq quoi
pouvons-nous apprendre pour demain et
donc c'est une chose très visuelle et c'est
une conversation c'est une conversation quotidienne
ça arrive dans les dépôts à chaque euh
chaque jour donc c'était tout à propos
s'améliorer chaque jour donc le côté culturel
de celui-ci, puis en l'intégrant avec certains
processus et quelques données pour conduire euh
performances en hausse
Elain, donc euh nous aussi, nous en avons regardé quelques-uns
plus gros, plus systémiques, euh, des changements, euh et
nous avons lancé euh ce que nous appelons le
initiative de projet de bateau qui était un
groupe de direction commun avec notre approvisionnement
chaîne connecter plus et connecter plus
Services euh et euh notre objectif fou était
ensemble, nous offrirons l'excellence sur
le
M25 et comme vous pouvez le voir en haut à gauche
slide, euh, il y avait six flux de travail, euh
et je vais juste souligner trois d'entre eux
les projets euh qui, je pense, ont été
particulièrement puissant dans ce que nous avons fait
euh, en bas à gauche, c'est ce que nous appelons
je me lance tard dans un projet Lean, donc c'est ça
un projet Lean qui chante et danse
euh, dirigé par l'un de nos leaders Lean, euh
ça dure plus d'un an maintenant et euh
ça va continuer mais ce que nous avons identifié
c'est que nous étions en train de gaspiller ou
perdre environ un million de livres par an
euh parce que nous n'arrivions pas au
réseau à 22h00, euh, ce qui est
notre temps libre sous le contrat euh et
et c'est une fenêtre de travail assez courte
donc il y a beaucoup de raisons pour lesquelles cela arrive
et ce projet a essayé de regarder
où sont les données comment nous faisons et quoi
problèmes pouvons-nous résoudre et en utilisant un ensemble
gamme d'outils Lean pour, euh, tout résoudre
ces différents
problèmes, le deuxième est l'optimisme, euh
qui est un outil d'optimisation de l'espace routier
c'est donc un bon exemple d'apprentissage
d'autres industries, donc euh, nous avons eu un nouveau
directeur rejoignez-nous euh qui a travaillé chez
Gatwick et auparavant dans l'eau
l'industrie et j'ai expérimenté cet outil qui
tu es rempli de tout ce que tu as
nécessaire pour livrer et tous vos
contraintes et il utilise l'IA pour, euh, je pense
ça vous donne environ 50 000
différentes options pour livrer votre
programme et ensuite vous choisissez le plus
les optimaux donc c'est un changement massif
à la façon dont nous réservons notre espace routier euh et et
Je pense que les optimistes nous le disent maintenant
c'est la plus grande application
de ce type de programme qu'ils ont
jamais fait
euh parce que c'est le
M25 et le troisième est alira euh donc
c'est un peu euh un peu
outil de planification en libre-service qu'il prédit
les niveaux de trafic, donc euh, une des raisons
euh, nous ne pouvons pas continuer à 10h00, c'est parce que
des volumes de trafic et de l’impact client
euh donc ça, euh, permettra aux entrepreneurs
pour regarder à quel niveau les niveaux de trafic
vont l'être et s'ils peuvent obtenir
on peut donc commencer plus tôt si le
les niveaux de trafic sont corrects, donc ça
nous espérons que cela nous permettra d'élargir notre
fenêtre de travail sans perturber le
client donc encore une fois un outil très puissant
euh et tout ça dans leur
la mise en œuvre impliquera euh un changement
les gens changent de comportement, c'est tellement énorme
changer les programmes derrière tout
c'est super merci euh Elaine donc euh nous
parlé d'Improv Pro chaque jour où nous avons
parlé des gens dont nous avons parlé
culture ela a parlé un peu des systèmes
et et les données alors qu'est-ce que le futur euh
ça ressemble à ça pour nous donc ce sont
Des tremplins donc des tremplins
à travers une rivière pour nous amener d'un endroit
à euh
un autre euh et dirigé par le renseignement
la maintenance entre dans une approche basée sur les risques
approche donc c'est ce que le succès futur
euh, on dirait que c'est celui à droite
côté main là je parle un peu plus
il s'agit du développement de ce qui est
appelé un Asos euh documenter l'Asos
le document fait ce que Sha a dit
écrire ce que nous voulons pour y parvenir
c'est aussi simple que ça, ça a l'air vraiment
des gens compliqués comme David Simpson
j'en serai très excité mais
au fond, c'est ça, c'est ça
c'est ce que c'est et les Stepping Stones euh
alors que vous arrivez aux plus grands ici, alors
vous pouvez voir ici la mise à jour de la maintenance
planifier les exigences d'évaluation du système
capturer l'évaluation des risques euh risque
gestion euh évaluation c'est un
approche systématique de quelque chose que nous
nous voulons influencer nous voulons euh Cibler
nos interventions de maintenance sont en place
activités basées sur l'intelligence mais vous
devons suivre cela opérationnel
principe d'excellence d'un euh systématique
approche afin qu'Asos Asset Service et
spécification écrivant ce que nous voulons
à réaliser, nous examinons donc ces éléments
pour tous les actifs donc il y en a un pour
tunnels un pour les structures un pour le soft
domaine un pour le trottoir et ce que nous sommes
ce que fait en ce moment c'est tant pis ce qu'Asos
c'est que nous avons une situation très compliquée
régime au Royaume-Uni selon lequel de nombreuses normes
lignes directrices, nous avons des obligations dans notre
contrat et ce que fait Asos, c'est
rassembler toutes ces choses dans
un seul endroit donc écrire ce qui est
requis de tous ces différents euh
éléments, ce que nous faisons alors est un écart
analyse, que dit Asos que nous devrions
faire et que faisons-nous en ce moment
va créer un écart, comment pouvons-nous gérer
avec cet écart quand nous comprenons comment nous
voulons traiter avec The Gap, comment pouvons-nous
vérifier l'approche dont nous avons alors besoin
enregistrer ces procédures et nous avons ensuite besoin
de le mettre à nouveau en œuvre de manière systématique
approche en commençant par ce que nous voulons
réaliser et progresser à travers un
processus de changement et
Amélioration et ce n'est qu'un exemple
tu n'as pas à t'inquiéter pour le euh
du contenu ici c'est un exemple
de ce que nous faisons en matière de drainage, qu'est-ce que
vous pouvez voir dans la section du milieu
euh, dans ces tableaux se trouvent les données dont nous sommes
collecter des données sur la quantité d'accumulation
là, dans cet actif de drainage de
Sil euh, comment ça fonctionnait, comment ça se passait
quels actifs avons-nous là-bas
et puis vous pouvez voir en bas là
décision éclairée en bas à droite, nous sommes donc
en regardant les données, nous regardons Asos
nous enregistrons les données que nous sommes
le mesurer et ensuite nous décidons
ce que nous allons en faire dans
l'avenir et ceci est la dernière diapositive donc
Amélioration continue et risque
évaluation à laquelle nous voulons parvenir
intelligence Le maintenance si seulement on
suivez Asos et tous les différents
lignes directrices dans lesquelles je reviendrai travailler ici
encore au cinéma parce que ce n'est pas
l'excellence opérationnelle qui consiste simplement à
un robot euh ces directives si nous
Implémentez chacun d’entre eux
ne sera pas commercialement viable, nous avons donc
nous devons être raisonnables, nous devons examiner
ce que les renseignements nous disent et
veiller à ce que nos activités correspondent aux
les informations qui sont là et qui laissent
Cela nous mène mais nous ne pouvons pas faire ça
comme exercice ponctuel, nous devons garder
je traverse ce cycle que tu vois
ici donc la planification et la programmation sont
travail entreprenant les activités au
les normes et les exigences qui
nous avons défini l'achèvement de l'enregistrement et
résultats et ensuite les réinjecter
année après année pour que nous puissions apprendre, euh
c'est donc ça l'excellence opérationnelle sur le
M25 c'est euh une nécessité merci pour
j'écoute ouais, c'est très impressionnant, je
souviens-toi d'avoir été dans ta salle de réunion et
vous disposez de nombreux tableaux de bord dans le
salle de réunion et ça marche, ce n'est pas seulement
ici pour afficher et montrer aux visiteurs
regarde, nous sommes géniaux, personne ne les utilise
exploiter les données et j'ai été vraiment impressionné
Y a-t-il
question oui une question
voila, eh bien, ma question s'adresse plutôt à
Shan euh je suppose que tu reconnais euh quoi
tu nous as présenté euh au début
de cela
session euh, je connais assez bien le a
approche Lean et je pense que ce que vous
mettre en place et continuer
M25 peux-tu me dire Shan si tu vois
aucune différence avec l'approche L euh
par rapport à euh, le design thinking est là
toute différence et lesquelles dans ceci
cas ouais, je ne pense pas qu'il y en ait
beaucoup de noms pour les mêmes choses parce que
en fin de compte, tout tourne autour des humains
euh mais je voudrais en passer un
question parce que je suis curieux
à propos de quand a-t-il fait un clic pour le
gens parce que des programmes efficaces sont
toujours quand vous implémentez quelque chose qui
les gens en bénéficient réellement, donc votre
opérateur disant ici les tableaux de bord sont
pas seulement les couleurs, elles me disent quelque chose
euh et je suis juste curieux de savoir ce qui s'est passé
cet argument convaincant où le
les gens disaient que je ne sais pas, tu viens dans le
matin, tu vois ce tableau de bord, j'ai un
beaucoup de choses à faire, comme c'était quoi cette chose où
il a en fait fait l'adoption parce que
ouais, euh, je pense que nous le faisons, euh nous présentons
aux euh les agents de première ligne tous les
trimestre et nous avons partagé certaines des données
avec eux et nous avons vu cela comme notre
les chiffres d'observation de la sécurité ont augmenté notre
le taux de fréquence des accidents a diminué
autrement, il y avait un clair
corrélation entre ces deux-là et vous
je peux voir le changement radical lorsque nous avons lancé
euh, j'améliore chaque jour la première catégorie
défauts que j'ai mentionnés euh plus tôt euh nous
ont atteint la performance des KPI dans neuf des
les 12 derniers mois au cours des 12 mois
avant ça, c'était trois sur 12 donc
je partage juste ces données avec euh
les agents de première ligne qu'ils étaient
vraiment heureux de le voir, nous ne l'aurions jamais fait
je l'ai déjà partagé avec eux, comment peut-il
vous délivrez l’excellence opérationnelle
sans réellement partager votre votre
l'ambition et les données avec les gens
qui font le travail donc je pense
pour répondre à ta question, c'était quand
on pouvait voir des gens s'engager avec le
performance, c'était significatif pour eux
c'était en quelque sorte logique, euh et
Je pense que l'autre élément qui a été
ce qui est vraiment important, c'est euh, nous quoi quoi
nous avons fait en nous améliorant chaque jour et
grâce à l'excellence opérationnelle, nous sommes
relier ensemble la sécurité personnelle
ce que je pense que les gens ont toujours
compris ou de mieux en mieux compris
pourquoi c'est important mais la sécurité du réseau
comprendre que ce que nous faisons
activités que nous entreprenons sur le réseau
veillent à la sécurité des usagers de la route
L'intendance du réseau le voit rapporter que c'est le cas
un message de sécurité, c'est une philosophie de sécurité
ce sont des gens qui se soucient les uns des autres et
l'usager de la route, engageant ainsi les gens avec
que méso l'observation de sécurité et
observations sur la gestion du réseau
continuer à augmenter euh nous avons même vu un
augmenter en janvier et février cette
année qui sont normalement les mois qui
nous avons vraiment du mal avec les chiffres
tout au long de l'hiver, donc euh
c'est toujours en cours, je pense qu'il y en a encore
énormément de choses, euh, encore énormément de choses à faire
mais je pense juste que cet engagement que nous
obtenu et le lien avec avec le
le message était très évident ouais
parce que je veux juste donner la réponse
de retour et les aners, je pense quel est le
différence entre tous ceux-là
méthodologies en fin de compte, c'est toujours le
pareil, c'est un peu comme
choisir votre fi et essayer
dis plusieurs fois que tu veux changer
quelque chose que tu avais peut-être appris ou que tu utilisais
Sigma Coman, quoi qu'il en soit, ça n'a pas fonctionné maintenant
tu viens avec le design thinking, disent les gens
qu'est-ce que le design thinking oh c'est un groupe
méthodologie et puis essentiellement vous êtes
je fais la même chose mais là où ça marche vraiment
c'est comme tu l'as montré quand les gens quand
c'est important pour eux donc si tu essayais
quelque chose que l'excellence opérationnelle a fait
ça ne marche pas quand tu viens avec euh Six Sigma
et trois ans plus tard quand tout le monde
je sais que tu inventes quelque chose de nouveau
mais en fin de compte, je pense que c'est comme la nourriture et
pour votre organisation et les gens veulent
changement, tu ne veux tout simplement pas manger le
la même chose tous les jours et c'est la même chose
organisation, donc si vous arrivez à des choses spécifiques
une partie avec l'excellence opérationnelle peut-être
trois ans plus tard tu as besoin de quelque chose de nouveau
vous démarrez un nouveau programme qui vous donne
nouvelle énergie mais essentiellement c'est toujours
la même chose concerne les humains et l'être
motivé et disant ouais ça fait
sens pour moi et puis c'est fondamentalement
le gagnant
argument merci beaucoup
à tel point que c'est l'heure de la pause
mais s'il vous plaît, une grande salve d'applaudissements, je
je pense que c'était vraiment
[Applaudissements]
impressionnant donc on se retrouve à 11h20 donc
prends un café et au fait, nous appelons PC
qu'est-ce que Bon
PC n'est pas le mot le plus simple merci
toi
alors maintenant je vais appeler Victoria merci
beaucoup d'être venu euh donc impulsion solaire
est très très célèbre en France je
j'ai découvert que ce n'était pas encore partout
L'Europe mais c'est comme un rockar beron quand
il vient quelque part et ils ont fait un
aventure incroyable et basée sur cela
aventure dans laquelle ils ont une belle histoire
soutenir une entreprise comme nous pour être un
Plus vert alors merci beaucoup, je vais
je te laisse le
micro
remercier
tu vas bien donc aujourd'hui nous parlions de
l'excellence opérationnelle pour nous
un autre monde mais c'est la même chose
l'efficacité, alors comment pouvons-nous faire un
monde efficace alors euh donc un
monde durable, alors maintenant vous pourriez
souviens-toi d'un vol autour du monde avec
un avion solaire c'est pour ça que je suis habillé
comme ça et maintenant tu demandes
toi-même, pourquoi sont-ils ici en train de nous parler
mais en fait nous sommes allés plus loin, nous y sommes maintenant
une organisation à but non lucratif appelée le S
fondation d'impulsion et ce film sera
euh, je t'aide à comprendre un peu
plus notre
[Musique]
voyage, chaque rêve de l'histoire était
considéré comme impossible jusqu'à ce qu'il soit
accompli derrière chaque réalisation
les explorateurs ont inventé le futur en
dépasser les frontières de
[Musique]
certitudes qu'ils ont enfreint les règles
remettre en question les hypothèses courantes pour
découvrir du nouveau
[Musique]
Les solutions d'aujourd'hui résolvent le problème
la crise environnementale semble hors du commun
Reach, nous avons besoin du même esprit pionnier
qui a, dans le passé, permis à l'humanité de
réaliser l'impossible, c'est ainsi que nous
trouverons les solutions pour changer le
World Beron P le visionnaire derrière l'énergie solaire
impulsion a voulu démontrer la
incroyable potentiel d'énergie renouvelable
énergies et technologies propres
Solar Impulsion a été construit pour transporter cela
message autour du
monde bonjour pulsation solaire bonjour capitaine
picart je m'inspire de ton esprit pionnier
Esprit vous connaissez Monsieur le Secrétaire Général si
un avion comme Solar Impulsion peut voler
jour et nuit sans carburant le monde de
le cours peut être beaucoup
nettoyeur
L'hôtel India Bravo tourne la finale 02
bien plus qu'une réussite dans le
L'histoire de l'impulsion solaire de l'aviation a
réalisé un exploit dans l'histoire de
énergie, prenons-la
en outre, ce qui peut être fait dans le ciel peut
être fait sur le terrain en remplaçant les anciens et
infrastructures polluantes par des infrastructures modernes et
des technologies efficaces sont logiques car
autant que
écologique convaincu la protection de
l'environnement deviendra une réalité
seulement si c'est économiquement viable
a lancé la deuxième phase de son
action engageant l'impulsion solaire
Fondation pour identifier 1 000 solutions
qui peut protéger l'environnement de manière
rentable
chemin
développé par des startups et des entreprises
ces Solutions réduisent la pollution et
améliorer l'efficacité dans les domaines de
eau énergie construction Mobilité
l'industrie et l'agriculture pour un meilleur
qualité de
vie évaluée par des experts indépendants et
labellisé par la Fondation solar impulse
ils représentent l'opportunité de marché de
le
siècle générateur d'emplois et propre
la croissance dans un avenir proche sera bêta
voyager à nouveau autour du monde pour présenter
cette sélection unique de solutions avec
un seul objectif : encourager les gouvernements
les entreprises et les institutions pour aller au-delà
compromis et fixer des objectifs plus ambitieux
objectifs environnementaux et énergie
politiques, là encore, l'esprit de
l'exploration a un rôle à jouer dans
réaliser ce que beaucoup de gens
considérer
impossible et vous pouvez faire partie de
[Musique]
et tu peux en faire partie, c'est
l'idée de mon objectif aujourd'hui avec vous est de
vous responsabiliser et vous le faire savoir à la fin
de la présentation pour laquelle nous sommes ici
vous présenter les solutions qui existent et
qui sont efficaces et qui devraient être
déployé aujourd'hui pas demain pas 2013 euh
30 20 50 c'est pour le moment juste une anecdote
mais cet avion qui ressemble à
l'avenir a en fait déjà 10 ans
et il a été construit avec des technologies qui
j'ai maintenant 10 ans donc je veux dire avec
la technologie d'aujourd'hui que nous pouvons déjà construire
le monde d'aujourd'hui mais dans un environnement moins polluant
et euh, de manière efficace, alors euh, qu'est-ce que c'est
sont-ils efficaces
Solutions
pour qu'il soit convaincant
les dirigeants décisionnels étant des gouvernements ou
des entreprises comme la vôtre, l'idée est que
nous devons aussi parler la bonne langue
donc si nous voulons juste dire à quel point c'est vert
ces solutions sont alors toutes les anciennes
des obstacles vont surgir dans votre
têtes dans les têtes du gouvernement, ce n'est pas le cas
assez mature ça coûte trop cher
le cadre réglementaire euh ne nous oblige pas
soit nous inciter à le faire dans
la fin on bouge pas donc nous le S
Impuls Foundation, nous avons créé ce label
l'impulsion solaire des solutions efficaces
étiquette pour prouver qu'il existe au moins un
des milliers de solutions qui existent oui
oui Pro, ils protègent l'environnement et
tu ne vas pas payer plus dans le
à la fin, tu vas économiser beaucoup
d'argent en remplaçant les anciens et polluants
infrastructure qu'il vous suffit de réaliser
les calculs sont corrects donc voilà
outil de persuasion dont nous avons beaucoup parlé
motivation euh
des projets significatifs donc ici ce n'est pas le cas
à peu près le e dans ESG mais Al c'est aussi
pour qu'une entreprise soit plus
efficace et euh plus
compétitif alors voici encore une fois vous
comprendre comment nous travaillons avec le
méthodologie de cette étiquette à chaque solution
Fournisseur de solutions donc la plupart d'entre elles sont
PME, startups mais aussi grandes entreprises
vous dans la pièce pourriez en fait avoir
développé ou travaillé avec certaines solutions
qui pourrait être qualifié tel quel et donc ceux
Les solutions doivent être conçues correctement
euh et réplique réplicable donc évolutive donc
ce n'est pas bien si ça va oui euh euh je
je prendrais l'exemple de l'âne mais si
tu es peut-être au milieu de Montal
ça ne marche pas donc c'est la solution
le fournisseur doit faire une analyse de rentabilisation
ok, ça marche là avec le
l'environnement et le contexte sont ainsi
c'est pour la crédibilité et
partie faisabilité, la deuxième partie est également
comment cette solution donne un incrément
avantages pour les clients en termes de
protéger la nature, alors comment faites-vous réellement
remplacer remplacer ancien et inefficace
solution donc ce n'est pas juste ce n'est pas le cas
mettre plus de technologies et de haute technologie
La technologie est présente dans tout ce qui concerne les gadgets
qu'il s'agit simplement de remplacer l'ancien par
être plus efficace et donc ce que nous avons
développée est la solution environnementale
outil d'impact pour lequel tout est gratuit
Innovateur de solutions pour obtenir le label
euh mais en gros, nous les aidons à obtenir un a
une simple analyse du cycle de vie de leurs
solution par rapport à un système traditionnel
alternative qui est courante en ce moment
cela ne devrait plus être courant
parce que ces solutions devraient être les
alternative grand public maintenant
c'est donc l'analyse que ces
Des solutions doivent être apportées, puis sur le
dernière partie et c'est ainsi que nous aussi toujours
dis que ce n'est pas une question de
écologie seulement, j'aurais dit du tout
mais oui bien sûr mais seulement c'est aussi un
question de rentabilité ou
compétitivité, c'est parce que pour le
quatrième critère, c'est vraiment la façon dont le
coût total de possession faisant à nouveau le
les maths sont corrects, euh c'est en fait pareil
ou inférieure à l'efficacité que le
instrument natif inefficace qui est
utilisé donc quand vous faites cela, vous
arrivé vous arrivez devant un client
vous montrez le retour sur investissement de ce spécifique
la technologie et puis ça a du sens
c'est pour ça que c'est une telle persuasion
outil de persuasion lorsque vous le souhaitez réellement
pour présenter des solutions comme
ce sont les solutions donc toutes celles-là euh
sont examinés par des experts indépendants
que si oui ou non, ils peuvent avoir le
l'étiquette pour toi aujourd'hui est importante, je vois
vous, en tant qu'adoptants, certains d'entre vous le sont
innovateurs très probablement mais aussi
adoptants, vous avez le pouvoir de réellement
déployer une infrastructure efficace et
en fait, certains de vos membres vous le demandent
clients euh alors comment pouvez-vous être euh par
adopter les solutions que vous pouvez augmenter
productivité parce que vous réduisez
coût à long terme, c'est aussi un
question de positionnement dans la valeur
chaîne et comment attirer davantage
clients et fidélisez également vos collaborateurs
avoir des gens heureux au sein des équipes c'est
aussi très important euh on l'a un peu entendu
plus tôt donc être dans un projet efficace
ça devient significatif et c'est ainsi
ces solutions plus efficaces sont au cœur
de certains des projets, euh, ce sera en fait
aidez votre entreprise à être plus compétitive
et euh
productif donc le changement est possible et dans
ce cas précis ce que nous disons quoi
berar dit que même si euh euh le
les solutions sont plus écologiques que
tout ce qu'ils sont est juste logique alors allons-y
euh, continue et adopte-en plus, donc euh
oui les solutions existent ici j'ai un a
quelques-uns d'entre eux que j'ai un peu présentés
plus tard, j'ai un atelier pour que tous ceux qui
veut venir voir cet outil euh
afin que nous puissions trouver des solutions pour votre
des projets pour lesquels je serais heureux de vous aider euh
alors maintenant je vais vous en montrer quelques-uns
de ces solutions qui ont été
étiqueté ainsi VT Rover, je sais que certains d'entre eux
vous êtes déjà êtes déjà ou dans le
processus d'essai de ce euh robot qui est
robot essentiellement 100% autonome avec
l'énergie solaire qui fait essentiellement le travail
désherbage euh sans glyphosate et ça
l'idée est vraiment une question de biodiversité
protection et euh pour le temps de récupération
est atteint en un an donc comme en tous
mes diapositives que tu verras toujours
ces deux axes parce que pour nous c'est propre
les technologies doivent être euh financièrement
viable maintenant si vous avez un prêt Mo alors
quelque chose d'autre que vous pouvez faire est aussi
en fait, valoriser ces déchets et euh certains
les blocs d'isolation sont en fait constitués de
c'est de l'herbe d'autoroute donc cette compagnie
Gramit, euh, est déjà en action
en France et en Suisse en Belgique et
euh propose aux promoteurs de maisons le
pareil euh, des coûts encore moins chers quand tu as
pour isoler votre maison, cela augmente la
efficacité en termes d'énergie
consommation de ladite maison et pour
toi, c'est du gâchis que tu ne paies pas
pour euh euh s'éloigner, c'est une façon de faire
alors peut devenir
Revenu un autre celui que nous avons entendu un
présentation sur Bim euh donc celui-là
aide tout technicien avec son téléphone haut
pour visualiser fondamentalement le
une infrastructure qui est euh au-dessus du
sol et donc en termes de déchets encore
c'est beaucoup de réduction des déchets dans
infrastructure parce qu'alors vous pouvez être
beaucoup plus précis dans la façon dont vous
en fait, euh, fais le travail, alors je reviens ici
des bénéfices environnementaux 50 % plus rapides
dessiner euh et neuf tonnes de carbone
émissions équivalentes sûres par travail
Roulez le retour sur investissement de ces solutions
évalués à six mois tous ceux
des chiffres parce qu'ici je ne suis pas
représentant l'une de ces solutions que je
je pense qu'il est important que tu saches cela
euh encore une fois, nous sommes une organisation à but non lucratif
nous n'avons de capitaux propres dans aucun d'entre eux
Solutions et ce que je dis ici, c'est que
ce que les experts ont vérifié, donc ce n'est pas le cas
juste les innovateurs qui ont
a présenté 100 fois à quel point ils sont géniaux
c'est nous qui avons examiné tout cela
des chiffres basés sur des études de cas concrets
que les innovateurs ont présenté à
nous un autre SEL NG c'est le Livin
plateforme, ce sont des données dont nous parlons
les villes intelligentes aussi, donc ici cela peut être un
outil intéressant pour le péage
fonctionnement de vos autoroutes alors voici le
et je voulais aussi prendre celui-ci
parce que ce n'est pas une startup, c'est une
solutions par NG donc c'est pour montrer le
les différents fournisseurs U que nous
peut avoir, il est capable de réduire le
la congestion du trafic de 30% et il y a
euh, autant d'économies que possible comme 108
millions de dollars par
année, je pense que c'est euh non, ce n'est pas le
le dernier euh c'est un autre système qui
J'ai entendu hier qu'en fait tu avais
j'ai essayé, donc je vous encourage à
tester et tester et tester ces solutions
autant que tu peux, euh, ça ne va pas
ça sera toujours aussi simple parce que tu
besoin d'avoir cet esprit pionnier mais
dans ce logo, en fait, aide-les simplement
pour peut-être aussi réifier un peu leur offre donc
euh, c'est un système que vous pouvez brancher
un véhicule thermique qui contribue à réduire
70% des pollutions toxiques et le ROI est
entre deux et 13 mois et qu'est-ce que ça
ce qu'il fait, c'est qu'il injecte de l'hydrogène dans le
dans le dans le moteur dans la combustion
moteur
désolé de protéger la nature euh
dans un précieux
en fait, c'est le dernier vrai, alors
tu ne l'es pas peut-être que ceux-là le sont aussi
des solutions que vous pouvez présenter à votre
des collaborateurs à proposer aussi euh à à
présenter des façons innovantes de faire les choses
donc ici en termes de rails euh c'est un
exemple de la Suisse mais nous en avons beaucoup
des voies ferrées qui sont vides en fait
où les centrales solaires pourraient être POS
position sur ce chemin de fer, puis le
l'énergie pourrait redevenir un revenu pour
pour le propriétaire foncier donc voici les revenus de
production et installation d'énergie 10
fois plus rapide pour le personnel spécialisé mais
tu vois sur la photo à quoi ça ressemble
comme ça, sois simplement innovant en gros
c'est le but d'essayer de nouvelles choses
des choses mais nous sommes là pour vraiment aider
tu es en train de les trouver
Solutions que nous avons créées en tant qu'organisation à but non lucratif
toutes ces connaissances disponibles sont sur notre
site Web dans la vidéo, vous avez entendu dire qu'il
c'était mille CH les 1 000 Solutions
défi J'ai rejoint la fondation nous
étaient-ils étiquetés à 300 solutions
maintenant nous en avons plus de 100 1 500
Solutions étiquetées et bien plus encore euh
nous savons et euh que nous poussons pour obtenir
l'étiquette euh mais donc il y a des filtres
vous pouvez utiliser en géographie le
la maturité de la solution ainsi que la
secteur bien sûr le type de clients donc
même pour toi, tu peux faire des affaires
euh service d'infrastructure, etc.
les filtres partent assez vite et de toute façon le
L'équipe de la Fondation s impul est là pour
soutien donc nous sommes une équipe de 40 collaborateurs
et comment ça marche, c'est que nous avons
les multinationales font des dons à cela
Fondation pour payer nos 40 employés
salaire en gros ce sont aussi Sol
les entreprises que nous aidons dans leur parcours
pour trouver les Sol Solutions et rencontrer
avec les innovateurs parfois même pour
changer la réglementation pour stimuler cela
adoption de technologies propres, euh, c'est ce que nous faisons
beaucoup d'activités différentes non seulement
c'est Al toujours pour stimuler l'adoption de
les technologies propres trouvent les solutions, mais
alors nous avons des activités de financement
eux euh via d'autres euh canaux financiers
que le nôtre mais au moins c'est tout pour
label Solutions dans lesquelles nous avons des activités
la partie plaidoyer aussi encore une fois
modifier le cadre réglementaire de la réglementation et
mon travail aujourd'hui représente l'essentiel du travail
en fait, pour vous faire savoir que le changement est
des solutions possibles existent et vous pouvez être
une partie de cela, tu peux, tu peux être un
Explorateur donc voici pour finir c'est le euh
la citation de Bertron Picar et c'est un
état d'esprit on reparlait
à propos de l'humain alors ayons cet état de
N'oubliez pas que lorsque nous faisons face à la vie, nous abandonnons
nos certitudes et nous l'utilisons réellement comme
parcourir la recherche de l'inconnu
parce que dans l'inconnu, c'est ici que tu
apprends que c'est ici que tu obtiens réellement
une motivation personnelle significative et ainsi
ici, je vais nous laisser cette image dans
cette phrase reste avec toi pendant un moment
quelques secondes mais euh c'est euh mon
présentation d'aujourd'hui merci beaucoup
tellement très inspirant euh comme tu le sais je
Je pense que tu comprends maintenant, notre travail n'est pas
juste rencontrer des kpis, c'est aller au-dessus et
au-delà afin que les solutions puissent être dans le
Edis Network, nous avons un excellent réseau et
certaines personnes aiment l'impulsion solaire pour les petits
histoire, j'étais en contact avec Victoria
grâce à notre ligne affaires aéroport
parce que nous avons un aéroport via le
groupe et grâce à l'aéroport nous sommes dans
contact et je trouve ça très excitant que tu
tu vois, ce n'est pas une révolution ce qu'ils
suggérer n'est pas une révolution, c'est
petite amélioration qui nous aidera à faire face
euh, ce changement climatique est un peu court
du temps donc pas de temps pour les questions mais
cet après-midi euh tu as deux ateliers
de 45 minutes où l'on entend pas mal
beaucoup de choses sur la fondation Solar Pulse, donc
maintenant j'aimerais appeler ma sœur pour le
prochaine euh présentation donc ma sœur et moi savons
l'un l'autre depuis quoi 15 ans quelque chose
comme cette carrière très impressionnante au sein
des âges et euh et plus à venir merci
nous allons parcourir le voyage dans
Kazakhstan et essayer de répondre à la
question qu'est-ce qu'une opération Excellence
depuis
hier, donc tout d'abord un aperçu de
le
projette l'histoire du succès et
comment nous revenons à la course de la liberté
lancer
l'industrie donc le projet est le Ring Road
de la ville d'Al Matic au Kazakhstan
reliant la partie orientale à la partie occidentale
la partie est 66
kilomet et c'était un projet financé par
ebrd et euh
l'objectif était de décongestionner un
un peu la ville parce que c'est très
encombré si vous allez où vous voulez
tu vois, tu passeras des heures et des heures
l'intérieur du
ville les sponsors principalement turcs Al
Malako à 50% et le Wes sud-coréen
et Korean Expressway a le rôle ici
être l'opéré
entreprise et c'est un c'est un c'est un
concession par période de 20 ans avec une
période de construction de 15 mois et 15
années de de de
opération euh comment c'est surtout moi euh je
mets cette diapositive juste pour te montrer comment
le projet est structuré mais l'onm
l'entrepreneur était déjà en place et nous
sont sous le courant sur le
l'entrepreneur actuel, nous sommes le
sous-traitant dû au régulateur
raison, qu'est-ce qu'on fait ici, c'est
une portée complète donc presque tout
collecte euh opération du dos
Trafic d'entretien hivernal des bureaux
gestion et c'est les principaux atouts
que tu peux voir sur le
projeter l'histoire en fait, elle a commencé en
euh dans 20
16 avant même que nous fassions partie d'un
Consortium qui était le concurrent de
l'actuel et pour une raison quelconque, nous
décidé de ne pas soumissionner et l'actuel
concurrent que le Consortium actuel a gagné
le projet réalise la clôture financière en
2019 et en juin
2023 euh, j'ai signé le contrat DM et
commencer à fonctionner le 16 juin
retour à la course quoi
c'est arrivé tout d'abord nous depuis 2016 nous
n'oublie jamais ce projet et il y avait
un marquage serré en français on a dit que
marot de notre partenaire Michel qui est
également présent en Turquie et nous avons
développé un partenariat fermé
notamment avec l'équipe commerciale et
Kadri
Bisal et euh
nous leur rappelons que nous sommes toujours là
quoi qu'il arrive s'ils ont besoin de conseils
tout ce qui concerne le projet, nous sommes un
partenaire en Turquie mais nous pouvons les aider
partout dans le
monde dans lequel nous sommes et le en même temps dans
2016 nous devenons le leader de l'onm
secteur en Turquie, il y avait deux
ouverture réussie euh dans le premier temps
de tout le projet Gab Isir qui a été
ouvert entre les deux
désolé qui était ouvert en différentes phases
entre 2016 et 2019 ainsi que le
ouverture réussie du tunnel ARA à
Décembre
2016 je n'en ai pas parlé mais nous aussi
la même année, nous exploitons le troisième
Pont qui était ouvert en août jusqu'au
Août 2016 à
2021 juste une vue de ce qu'est g zmir c'est
un gros atout plus de 500
kilomètre d'autoroute en exploitation
et nous opérons à travers un Gib ismir
une société qui est détenue à 50% par
concession AOL et 50% est Road
opération euh et M fait partie de ça euh de
le concessionnaire lequel de ce projet
à travers le
excellence opérationnelle du concessionnaire
tu as dit, ce n'est pas seulement faire ce que tu as
faisons chaque jour nous gérons davantage
plus de 90 incidents par jour et nous sommes sur
temps
avec
désolé, c'est assez impressionnant d'être là
devant toi c'est
[Rire]
pourquoi 19 étudiants gèrent chaque jour
quotidiennement et nous devons être sur place dans
moins de 30 minutes euh c'est seulement ça
Reste la seule autoroute ouverte pendant
la tempête hivernale pendant la saison
20121 et il y a un mensuel
rapprochement qui est fait chaque mois
dans les cinq jours ouvrables pour obtenir le
concessionnaire se faire payer
le temps comme tu le sais l'argent euh l'argent c'est très
important dans notre projet
et surtout pour l'escroquerie pour le
concessionnaire donc nous devons être à l'heure
comme nous l'avons dit, il ne s'agit pas seulement d'effectuer ce que
nous le faisons tous les jours mais c'est aussi
aller au-delà de ce que tu fais donc tu
il faut être innovant pour cela et nous
commencer à utiliser un équipement différent
pour que l'entretien hivernal en fasse partie
du reste du secteur comme le
le pick-up que vous balancez sur le
main droite
côté et nous sommes aussi
surveiller l'actif pour le moment où nous sommes
surveiller l'actif pour le
satellite euh parce que c'est
y avait-il un problème de pente sur le
sur le projet et le satellite a été
aider, c'était aider le concessionnaire
avoir une vision claire de ce que quoi
est
se passe donc pour obtenir nous obtenons l'identification de
le concessionnaire nous nous nous avons été
reconnu comme le leader en tant que
transparent euh opération opération
entreprise et ils croient en eux
croire en
nous donc en octobre
2022, nous avons reçu un appel un jour et ils
dit que nous avions l'intention d'ouvrir l'arrière à
projet
dans
Janvier, pouvez-vous faire une vérification diligente pour
nous parce que dans trois
mois, c'est plutôt intelligent, c'est plutôt intelligent
un court un court laps de temps pour ouvrir
et peux-tu aller voir ce que c'est
se passe et pouvez-vous nous informer si
si c'est possible de le faire
donc nous y sommes allés, nous en avons identifié quelques-uns
optimisation on épingle on on leur donne
conseils sur l'entretien hivernal que nous
revoir avec eux la portée complète de notre travail
identifier comme le risque lié au à
ouverture pendant la pendant la
hiver
et après discussions
nous, nous leur avons dit que ce serait très
difficile à ouvrir pendant le
en plein hiver sans camions
parce que les camions n'étaient pas là et euh
nous
nous, je suis vraiment désolé pour
c'est donc nous nous avons un long disque nous avons
une discussion avec avec mol et le
Turc et ils ont dit concernant le dû
diligence et ce que vous avez fait pendant
ce jour-là, es-tu capable de gérer le
opération et nous avons dit que nous le sommes, nous sommes capables
pour gérer cela, alors faites-nous une proposition, mais
est-il possible d'ouvrir pendant l'hiver
nous allons
voir
et alors
nous euh à travers ce que nous ce que nous avons fait c'est
c'est aussi une des raisons d'être
de retour sur la course, c'est la capacité de euh
la capacité de conserver à livrer dans un délai
courte période de
le temps, euh, les activités préopératoires et
Les négociations commerciales se sont déroulées en
en parallèle nous avons pris le risque de commencer par
en même temps la discussion commerciale
avec Olivia
Bertram euh patri prend la décision pour
ça et on commence la pré-opération avec
mobilisation de l'équipe G en Turquie et
également l'accompagnement de l'expert à travers
le à travers le
siège social, euh, les managers locaux étaient
recruté soit euh très vite on connait le
environnement à quel point c'était complexe et dans
moins de six semaines six semaines nous sommes
capable de recruter davantage
que plus de 100
les gens euh pour commencer l'opération
en fait l'opération nous ils étaient
convaincu de ne pas démarrer pendant le pendant
pendant l'hiver, il a été retardé
mars et après cela, il a été reporté à
en juin pour la politique et pour
opérationnel
raison pour laquelle nous étions
très
rapidement les gens ont été formés sur place
et certains managers sont venus en Turquie
aussi être
s'entraîner euh nous, merci à l'équipe de
G ils sont allés régulièrement sur place
à faire les rencontres avec le
fournisseurs avec le
concessionnaires et avec tous les
sous-traitants et le démarrage de
l'opération a été faite le 16 juin euh le
direction de anal gmir qui est le général
le gestionnaire de son infrastructure est
gestion des infrastructures
Le Kazakhstan et euh le système de libre circulation
était en opération si je me souviens bien
TW sur le tiers de
Juillet donc
quelques photos sur le projet comme
Je peux vous montrer comme vous pouvez voir le
salle de contrôle
route l'onm centre et le pmv et le
VMS que vous pouvez
voir BMS est également et le
j'arrive à la fin pour la question quoi
c'est quoi c'est quoi c'est quoi
l'excellence opérationnelle c'est à moi d'être
un durable un durable
leader donc tu as tu peux être leader dans
le marché et comme vous l'avez dit, vous êtes le
toi tu veux être celui qui
doit être suivi mais vous pouvez l'être
suivi pendant un certain temps
pour moi, cela devrait être durable pour
une longue période de temps et tout est basé
sur les humains comme Shan l'a dit aussi, je suis d'accord
là-dessus parce que derrière ça nous sommes
livrer un
service et quelles personnes malheureusement
ce que les gens garderont à l'esprit lorsque vous
Je demande quel est ton, quel est ton
performances de l'AIS de votre de votre
sous-traitant ce sera ce sera le
fait quand tu
échouer si je vous demande quelle est la citation
comment n'as-tu pas itéré ton avion
entreprise, vous rappellerez à l'heure comment
combien de fois il l'a été
tard tu ne te rappelleras pas quand nous serons
effectuer à temps tout cet accident sur
temps parce que les gens pensent que
c'est un duw pour
eux donc tu dois aller au-delà de ce que tu as
pour aller au-delà et il faut innover
et tu dois euh proposer
quelque chose de différent qui te maintient là
dans leurs
l'esprit et les gens qui sont différents
entreprise différente et innovante
comme l'impulsion solaire tu la gardes tu la gardes
en tête, c'est comme les joueurs de football aussi
pourquoi Kilan pourquoi pourquoi Kilan Mbappe est là
ton esprit parce qu'il est différent, il est
surperformant, tu ne rappelles pas le
surmonter euh tu ne restes pas à l'intérieur
fais attention aussi à ce que tu gardes seulement à l'esprit
champion quand ils gagnent la finale tu es
je ne me rappelle pas qui a perdu la finale donc
c'est très important
[Musique]
à à pour conserver cette performance cette
leadership sur le sur le
temps merci
toi
alors je t'ai vu, je t'ai vu aller au Caro
bar hier après le dîner donc
c'est probablement pour ça que tu as perdu ton
voix il y a deux jours, il était au a
casquette à Istanbul présentant une innovation
nous essayons de mettre en œuvre ce qui est
patrouiller par drone euh autoroute que nous
je pense que c'est beaucoup plus efficace, alors il est
mettre beaucoup d'énergie là-dessus alors merci
merci beaucoup pour votre présentation
merci merci et désolé pour le
pour la voix pour la voix et le Koke
euh et et mais c'est une très belle histoire
parce que parfois nous avons du mal sur un projet
mais la bonne histoire, c'est quand tu travailles dur
lorsque vous apportez de la valeur à vos clients
concessionnel enfin tu as
quelque chose de bien à la fin merci beaucoup
merci beaucoup
toi et moi aimerions appeler Barbara et
Oran pour parler de santé et sécurité
ce qui est bien sûr un
problème ou préoccupation majeur majeur non seulement un
problème, j'espère que je vous laisserai expliquer
ça merci
donc euh tout d'abord merci beaucoup
de nous accueillir ici aujourd'hui, c'est un super
plaisir de parler devant vous
euh, santé et sécurité, pas de surprise, il est un
matière humaine et c'est une affaire humaine dans
deux aspects que je pense avant tout
nous, nous voulons revenir sains et saufs à la maison
le soir après notre temps de travail et est
la même chose pour toutes les équipes qui sont
travailler pour
nous mais la santé et la sécurité sont aussi une affaire humaine
importe particulièrement pour nous parce que nous
tous ont une responsabilité dans la santé
et la sécurité des personnes dans notre périmètre afin
c'est pourquoi c'est particulièrement important
pour que vous soyez pleinement conscient de
C'est la réalité et tu le sais mieux
que moi, c'est que Ro opère dans
en particulier sont assez risqués par nature et
quand j'ai rejoint l'AIS il y a deux ans, j'ai regardé
aux statistiques dont je disposais
terme d'accidents et malheureusement il
ce ne sera pas une surprise pour vous mais majeur
la plupart des blessures graves et
décès survenus au sein de l'AIS en
les dernières années étaient dans les opérations routières
activités afin de mettre en valeur les
importance du sujet ici et juste
depuis le début de l'année je pense
nous sommes aujourd'hui à
113 accidents depuis le début de
2023 donc
encore une fois, cela souligne l'importance et
criticité du sujet au sein de Road
opération à nouveau par nature parce que euh le
la nature du travail parce que nous
ne peut pas contrôler pleinement l’environnement
d'autres conducteurs qui arrivent sur le
route qui crée plus de risques si l'on compare
aux activités d'ingénierie dans le
groupe
donc je sais que c'est déjà un gros effort pour
vous et votre équipe maintenez cela
environnement sûr mais nous pouvons d'abord
toujours améliorer cela et c'est aussi
un des thèmes de l'opérationnel
l'excellence est permanente et continue
Amélioration et à mesure que nous grandissons
parce que nous entendons de bonnes nouvelles concernant
les affaires et les nouvelles entreprises sont
une ouverture qui est encore plus importante
capable d'apporter ça à euh le nouveau
projets que nous ouvrons donc nous avons
mettre en place une nouvelle stratégie nous y sommes
à soutenir et je pense que vous savez très bien
eh bien, avec qui je parle, euh
aujourd'hui c'est très important pour moi ça
Barar est là euh
aujourd'hui, regardons un chiffre, euh
vite c'est
120% c'est le bénéfice net de tous les efforts
budget que vous consacrerez à la santé et
sécurité car par nature vous obtiendrez un
profitez-en car cela aide votre
les opérations pour être plus efficaces
productif et il a beaucoup de direct
et bénéfice indirect mais maintenant je laisse
Barbara a expliqué que de plus en plus
détaillé
manière
merci Orel Young et euh oui, ça l'est
impressionnant d'être devant vous aujourd'hui
voyons comment ça se passe, euh, j'aimerais
commence par une liste de ce que j'appelle
ingrédients du succès ceci est une liste
des bienfaits qui résultent de la santé et
sécurité
Les investissements euh et les investissements sont
les actions quotidiennes que nous entreprenons pour faire de notre
lieux de travail plus sûrs et certains d'entre eux
les avantages peuvent être directement euh
évalué en termes de retour euh
diminution de l'absentisme
ce n'est peut-être pas aussi évident ou apparent pour vous
donc j'aimerais les garder sur le
écran pendant un moment si vous ne le faites pas
fais attention à tous ces ingrédients pendant que je
les appeler sont essentiels si notre ambition
c'est l'excellence en matière de santé et de sécurité, mais je
j'aimerais croire que c'est aussi
essentiel si notre ambition est l'excellence
en général et juste un commentaire sur le
productivité, je pense avoir entendu le mot
avant d'avoir une phrase, un lieu de travail sûr est
un productif
lieu de travail, c'est tout autant que ça, mais
cette déclaration me permet de prendre
étape supplémentaire et prétendre que c'est sûr
le lieu de travail est un lieu de travail innovant
potentiel et si nous comprenons que c'est
Innovant car prendre le risque
je vois probablement déjà un lien clair
entre Innovation et santé et
la sécurité mais pour moi, euh, je crois que nous devons
être sûr et stable
environnement pouvoir prendre prendre
de nouveaux risques et d'examiner les
inconnu et à rechercher Nouveau
Opportunités et nouveautés innovantes
solutions dont nous avons besoin en matière de santé et de sécurité
santé environnement sain et sûr
où euh nos processus Pro actuels et C
les activités actuelles sont exercées dans un
manière stable et continue du début à
finir, je crois que c'est seulement à ce moment-là que notre
un vrai potentiel d’innovation peut être
révélé mais revenu à la réalité
donc assez pour l'instant du positif
avantages et parlons-en, euh,
une réalité qui est exigeante et toi toi
je sais que vous le savez tous, ça peut être exigeant
juste deux exemples de la santé et
événements de sécurité que nous avons enregistrés plus tôt
année et le premier vient du
route sur euh domaine M c'était euh haut
proximité potentielle donc un événement qui a été
en fait, très proche de plusieurs
des morts, euh, il ne s'est rien passé mais ça
était vraiment très proche et le deuxième
on vient du domaine ferroviaire oui je
je sais que c'est hors du champ d'application mais là
y a-t-il des similitudes entre les deux événements
et la seconde était une situation majeure
et majeur euh avec un M majuscule je ne le ferai pas
entrer dans les détails des accidents, mais
Je voudrais euh montrer les similitudes
euh donc nous pouvons tirer la leçon pour que
d'abord euh
similitude qui est en fait la
conséquences euh cas à fort impact élevé
avoir des conséquences à la fois sur les individus
impliqués mais aussi sur les entreprises à
les entreprises, euh, en termes de contrats
implications client
implication dans des investissements ad hoc
réorganisation et aussi dans le deuxième
cas euh potentiel
réputation, euh, risque à à à à
réputation parce que c'est le deuxième cas
a été très médiatisé dans
médias, les deux cas ont évidemment été analysés
pour des causes et une autre
similarité euh la piste de causalité
facteurs très similaires deux cas différents
deux domaines différents et en fait deux
différents continents et la trace de
facteurs très très similaires, euh, je pense que
c'est un test de réalité pour nous, euh, d'une certaine manière
que parfois c'est simple pour notre
défenses de santé et de sécurité que nous essayons
construire si dur avec nos investissements
donc pour que ces défenses soient compromises
très très
facilement euh mais en même temps
il est temps que cette vérification de la réalité soit
nécessaire euh parce que nous devons rester
vigilant, nous devons garder les yeux sur
la santé et la sécurité du tout
le temps et euh laissez-moi admettre que c'est aussi
légèrement
frustrant d'une manière constructive euh pour
je vois les mêmes facteurs venir euh venir
encore et encore
encore une fois mais encore une fois c'est une opportunité car
eh bien, si on voit ça
euh, les raisons des accidents sont
identifiable si nous gardons cela à l'esprit, nous
pouvons agir et nous pouvons prendre les mesures
plomb
et ce que nous devons réaliser ce que nous
j'aimerais réaliser est en fait tout à fait
simple, euh, c'est une définition proposée
pour l'excellence en matière de santé et de sécurité, c'est
comment nous le voyons et j'espère que vous le remarquerez
que la définition amène un humain
La santé et la sécurité sont une affaire humaine
c'est important donc il y a un aspect humain
dans cette définition et la définition est
que l'excellence en matière de santé et de sécurité peut
ne sera atteint que si chaque employé voit
la valeur d’effectuer un travail en toute sécurité et
cette valeur va au-delà de la sécurité
la sécurité personnelle qui est primordiale mais
cela s'étend également à la sécurité des processus
savoir que ce que nous faisons du début à
la finition est terminée
constamment en toute sécurité et de manière stable et je suis
désolé, je pense que je fais du karaoké
chose aussi donc je vais m'excuser
jusqu'au bout, je le promets
euh, cette définition, la définition serait
ne pas être
complet sans couche supplémentaire et je
je pense qu'il est important de voir
euh, l'excellence en matière de sécurité ne sera pas
atteint si notre personnel ne sait pas comment
réagir s'ils voient que la valeur du coffre-fort
le travail est
compromis donc euh, ça peut paraître simple
parce que tout ce que nous attendons, c'est qu'ils sachent
que quelque chose ne va pas, ils le savent
ils peuvent et doivent réagir et ils savent
comment
réagir mais je crois en la réalité et
souviens-toi que ça peut être
Ming euh, cela n'arrivera peut-être pas et les deux
deux événements que j'ai montrés
plus tôt, euh, ça
intervention, euh, n'a été compromis, personne
empêché les raccourcis d'être pris et
personne n'a arrêté l'utilisation d'équipements dangereux
utilisé comme ça
cela arrive et euh, dernier commentaire final, j'espère
tu te souviens de la sécurité
attitude si tu le fais, c'est fantastique
parce que l'attitude en matière de sécurité ne va pas
loin euh nous allons continuer avec
cette méthodologie dans le cadre du um
parcours d'excellence en matière de sécurité, alors euh maintenant
ça suffit de Kari, je rends la parole
à Oro merci beaucoup pour votre
attention oh merci
barabar et Bravo euh alors comment faire
nous y parvenons, vous avez donc vu notre
définition de la santé et de la sécurité
Excellence euh pourquoi c'est important alors comment
est-ce que nous y parvenons déjà
la Direction tout d’abord en 2021 a
la décision a été prise de renouveler le
stratégie que nous avons sur ce sujet également
sur les aspects de sécurité euh avec le XCOM donc
J'ai rejoint AIS en 2021 suite au
arrivée de Laurman avant de suivre le
nouvelle feuille de route la nouvelle stratégie du
groupe afin de pouvoir accompagner
la croissance et la stratégie du groupe
donc nouvelle stratégie 2021 validée sur ces derniers
euh, les sujets sur lesquels 2022 étaient vraiment axés
consolider nos ressources notre
capacités donc avec notamment l'arrivée
de Barbara que la plupart d'entre vous connaissent très bien
eh bien, c'est un grand plaisir d'avoir
Barbara dans l'équipe parce qu'elle est
apporter beaucoup de The Experience
elle avait euh en opération routière et donc elle
je peux partager cela avec le groupe qui est
c'est aussi un bon moyen de bénéficier
notre expertise interne donc maintenant nous avons
expertise au niveau central 2023 ce
l'année est très importante pour nous car
vous avez peut-être vu que nous avons
formalisé une nouvelle politique en matière de santé et de sécurité
et Sécurité, nous avons de nouveaux KPI que nous
sont en train de déployer à l'échelle mondiale que tous
les activités à travers le groupe utiliseront nous
ont également adapté la structure à la
nouveau modèle opérationnel de fonctionnement du
groupe et que ces éléments seront
vraiment permettre l'année prochaine d'avoir un
Base solide pour avoir une plateforme évolutive
structure pour avoir des données disponibles et
nous pourrons donc prendre des risques en fonction
décision décision basée sur les données afin
aux cycles d’améliorations en matière de santé et
la sécurité dans le prochain
années et je pense, comme je l'ai dit dans
introduction, c'est très important dans le
contexte de croissance du groupe
car il contribue à assurer la croissance de
bien sûr, un incident majeur pourrait avoir un impact sur notre
réputation notre croissance, c'est donc
quelque chose que nous voulons tous éviter mais aussi
c'est un levier et j'insiste vraiment
que nous pouvons réellement utiliser la Santé, la Sécurité et
La sécurité comme niveaux pour accélérer notre
la croissance parce que cela aide à être efficace
être rentable et ainsi croître et
pour accomplir la feuille de route la stratégie
de la
groupe et donc pour ça et c'est pourquoi nous
sommes ici aujourd'hui, nous avons absolument besoin de vous
en être convaincu et être
les ambassadeurs doivent vraiment insister sur ce point
en avant et nous sommes ici aussi pour
présentez-vous si vous ne nous connaissez pas
au moins maintenant c'est le cas, alors n'hésitez pas à
tendre la main à Barbara et à moi-même et
nous serons très heureux de vous soutenir merci
merci beaucoup pour votre temps aujourd'hui et
heureux de répondre
question, nous avons le temps pour une question
si tu
je veux la France
oui le micro arrive merci
à toi euh merci pour la présentation d'abord
tu voulais dire mentionner un avantage net d'un
plus
120%, comment a-t-il été calculé dans le
fin, c'est international euh
Institut de sécurité et de sûreté je suis
désolé si je n'évoque pas le nom
correctement dans la présentation, vous
voir en note de bas de page une petite référence
donc c'est confirmé par la recherche, ce n'est pas le cas
facile à calculer euh les avantages et à apporter
vous connaissez des chiffres concrets mais basés sur
la recherche et cela a été fait aussi
au sein de l'Union européenne et dans une entreprise
ont été vérifiés et interrogés sur
divers facteurs de santé et de sécurité afin
il y a
ressources um fondées sur des preuves confirmant
que c'est 120% et je vous invite à avoir
un coup d'oeil euh euh sur le lien et et et et
vérifier le Le
Source merci merci
donc tu dois me donner le nom de ça
K Bar parce qu'évidemment ça a l'air
très sympa donc merci beaucoup exactement
alors merci si tu veux tu peux tu peux
euh, retourne à ta place, je pense que tu
je dois partir rapidement alors merci beaucoup
beaucoup pour votre temps, je m'occuperai de
dernier
présentation euh Ed Got
Talent, qu'est-ce que ça te dit quand je le dis
tu es un Just Got Talent, en as-tu
idée de ce que je vais faire, est-ce que nous
je vais faire la voiture, ok
ou danser danser pour que tout le monde veuille
danser avec qui qui d'autre veut danser
non, pas moi, donc c'est juste du talent, alors
vous avez vu que nous avons un incroyable
Un réseau très diversifié Un réseau différent
pays différent
continent euh différents systèmes parfois
Urbain inter Urbain nombreuses autoroutes nombreuses
aéroports incroyable réseau d'aéroports et
toute la journée nous avons dit ce qui est important
ce sont les gens, les gens alors peut-être qu'il est temps de
fais briller notre peuple, n'est-ce pas
tu le penses, ce que nous lançons, nous le faisons
lancement d'une innovation et d'un prix
défi, le but est donc de favoriser
Innovation, nos collaborateurs réussissent très bien
vous avez vu que nous avons un excellent réseau
partageons entre nous ce que nous faisons de bien
et il n'y a même pas que toi dans la pièce
si tu es très important mais c'est aussi
vos superviseurs vos ouvriers routiers où
vos collecteurs de péage votre entretien
équipe votre équipe comptable votre équipe humaine
équipe ressource et j'oublie beaucoup de monde
ils font des choses géniales alors partageons quoi
si vous le faites, nous aurons deux défis et
oui, bien sûr, fais en sorte que tu fasses ton équipe
brille et euh tu vois, nous avons ce nouveau
logo un groupe pousse beaucoup
Innovation et nous avons ce nouveau logo pour
pour l'innovation et nous avons le soutien
du laboratoire que nous avons développé, je vois que j'étais
je suis sur le point d'avoir des ennuis si j'oublie
le labo L Cosmono était à la tête de l'Innovation
pour le groupe euh lancer une initiative
où nous soutenons l'entrepreneuriat I
je ne sais pas, tu dis ça en anglais
l'entrepreneuriat euh donc les gens qui ont
un IDE les aidera à développer un
démarrage et peut-être l'avantage du
affaires des âges dans les 10 prochaines années
ne sera plus autoroute ou
ingénierie, ce seront peut-être ceux-là
startups voyons voir donc c'est ce que nous
je veux atteindre et bien sûr briller est
sympa mais ayant des récompenses financières
et aussi la reconnaissance sont importantes donc
nous allons permettre à notre personnel de pitcher devant
du top management d'Ages donc là
il y a deux catégories, l'une est la plus simple
pense que le
mais nous aimons les défis, l'un est l'excellence
décerné ainsi au cours des 18 derniers mois de votre
entreprise, vous avez mis en œuvre des choses formidables
ça pourrait être des choses mineures, comment tu t'améliores
sécurité comment améliorer euh durable
développement comment améliorer votre péage
collection peu importe, dis-nous ce que tu as fait
dites-nous que cela prend 30 minutes
le formulaire, dis-nous ce que tu as fait, tu as déposé
cela sur la plateforme web et nous le ferons
votez, l'autre est présent pour les 18 prochains
mois, que comptez-vous faire en termes
de l'innovation, vous avez une pièce d'identité, cela pourrait
sois juste une pièce d'identité, donne-la-nous parce qu'alors
nous essaierons de vous aider à mettre en œuvre
Innovation et ce sera peut-être un
démarrage dans les prochaines années et peut-être
dans deux ou trois ans, peut-être dans le prochain
l'année ce sera tout autour de l'AES
Mettez en réseau votre identifiant pour que vous voyiez que nous voulons
faire briller les gens, nous avons un super
Réseau, exploitons-le et nous avons
cette plateforme s'appelle agor donc en termes de
c'est le moment où nous le lançons aujourd'hui, mais soyez
attention, ce n'est pas seulement l'autoroute, c'est aussi
l'aéroport c'est la mobilité c'est le train c'est un
Le conseil, c'est tout notre métier
ont un secteur d'activité incroyable
différentes compétences, c'est pour tout le monde, donc
voyons qui gagne donc nous avons euh le
chronologie ici donc il y aura un a
comité directeur qui votera pour
leur avis les meilleures pièces d'identité et là
ce sera euh un pitch pour cinq d'entre eux et
le gagnant il y a aussi le vote
phase pour le public donc sur cette plateforme
n'importe qui peut se connecter et dire que j'aime cet identifiant
et vous donnez des points non seulement à votre
amis mais seulement pour projeter la livraison
valeur et ensuite vous obtenez euh le
gagnants donc c'est ce que nous faisons et
c'est la plateforme agor donc je le ferais
je tiens à remercier beaucoup Orre qui est
Tu te caches derrière Orre, pourrais-tu venir, je savais
toi tu voulais venir ici je te connaissais
je suis allé à la voiture aussi hier mais je voudrais
sois gentil si tu le pouvais
venez et une grande salve d'applaudissements pour
parce que c'est elle
récompense d'anniversaire super cadeau Richard
merci beaucoup
elle, elle adore être dans la série mais moi
j'ai dit aujourd'hui non, pas pour toi aujourd'hui ensuite
du temps alors merci beaucoup elle elle
travaillé très dur avec l'équipe ici pour
développer ceci pour que nous puissions le lancer
début de semaine prochaine, vous recevrez
le lien pour tout donc c'est tout
pour
aujourd'hui euh donc je laisse les derniers mots à
à aan et je prendrai le micro
après euh merci beaucoup euh Richard merci
euh j'espère que tu as apprécié le
présentations K ou pas euh et bien je ne le suis pas
bien sûr, si tu sais clairement quoi
l'excellence opérationnelle signifie, euh, je pense
J'ai entendu tout ce à quoi je m'attendais
vois dans la définition de toute façon euh je ne le suis pas
je vais faire un long discours, le seul
chose à qui je voulais dire merci
Richard euh et l'équipe euh je ne sais pas
si tu peux le voir, tu connais le meilleur
les émissions sont celles que l'on ne voit pas vraiment
les cordes et tout le reste, euh, il y a
il y a eu beaucoup de travail en cours dans le
préparation d'aujourd'hui et de ce qui se passe
à venir cet après-midi, beaucoup de
préparation à ce qui s'est passé hier
merci beaucoup à toutes les personnes qui
a fait
présentation euh c'était vraiment génial de
il faut avoir un aperçu de notre projet pour
avoir la participation de personnes telles que
méridium ou impulsion solaire merci beaucoup
euh, merci beaucoup à tous ceux qui sont présents
le dos qui ne se voit pas vraiment
ils sont venus devant et j'ai fait beaucoup de choses
travailler aussi en arrière-plan en faisant tout
de toute la préparation donc un gros
merci et une grande série d'applaudissements à tous
de
eux oui merci je veux vraiment remercier
toi Emin, elle n'est pas là parce qu'elle est
je prépare déjà euh le déjeuner qui est
voiture importante en France dont tu te souviens
tu t'entraînes pour le déjeuner des Français
sont importants et euh et aussi le
Salle d'innovation, alors quelle est la prochaine étape maintenant, nous
je retournerai à pied au quartier général
nous avons donc parlé de l'opération Excellence
Je dois m'excuser, nous en avons encore
marge d'amélioration pour le transfert de
hôtel ici parce que certaines personnes étaient
penser à l'IB Hotel n'avait pas
information, nous n'avions pas de bus aujourd'hui, donc
ils ont attendu et la deuxième amélioration est un
météo parce que c'était terrible
il pleut donc travailler à 500 mètres est généralement
bien, pas aujourd'hui, donc vraiment désolé, non
excusez-moi pour cela, pour l'année prochaine, nous le ferons
mets ça dans notre liste de choses à faire, alors qu'est-ce que c'est
viens ensuite donc si certaines personnes ont une voiture
ce serait génial s'ils pouvaient attendre
en haut des escaliers à gauche donc si
ils pourraient aller chercher des gens parce que je
je ne sais pas comment sont les prévisions météo
en ce moment mais s'il pleut et que je
je suppose qu'il pleut, euh s'ils pouvaient prendre
un deux trois personnes différentes, c'est un
bon moyen de se rencontrer et de traverser
fécondation donc si les personnes qui ont un
la voiture peut attendre au sommet et ceux qui veulent un
la voiture peut peut-être se connecter avec
leur salle d'innovation donc l'innovation
la salle va commencer euh début du
après-midi donc vous verrez très
pièce d'identité intéressante, essayez de passer du temps
là, engagez une demande d'inscription pour
tes différents ateliers et démos euh je
je pense que c'est génial et j'ai sûrement oublié
ouais, je voulais remercier tout le monde mais
tu es trop fort, je l'ai fait avant
de moi alors merci beaucoup pour votre
attention super merci pour le
haut-parleurs j'ai adoré ils ont très bien travaillé
dur très très dur j'ai adoré
tout le monde est à l'heure, je n'étais pas obligé
crabe le fouet tellement content de ça alors je
je n'ai même pas utilisé mon ouais je n'ai pas utilisé
eux, j'étais tellement bouleversé et j'ai dit que j'avais mon
le rouge, je vais montrer mon rouge
parce qu'hier, on m'a montré un rouge
un quand il me restait 30 secondes
et c'est une expérience, ok, profite-en
le reste de la journée à 18 heures. Bien
divulguer le nom du restaurant pour que je
je sais qu'il y a beaucoup de pression sur nous pour
donne-le mais on attendra 18h. donc toi
il faut aller sur l'application d'engagement
à voir alors profite du reste de la journée
[Applaudissements]
au revoir